ओके। सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव। अ लेट मी
चेक।
एक बार चेक करता हूं मैं।
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस। लेट मी चेक वंस इफ आई
एम लाइव।
ओके। सो फाइनली वी आर लाइव एंड प्लीज मुझे
बता दीजिए एक बार सभी। इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल। आवाज सही से आ रही है आप लोगों
को? दिख रहा हूं मैं अच्छे से क्लियरली।
कोई लैग, कोई प्रॉब्लम, कोई इशू तो नहीं
है? एक बार बता दीजिए। फटाफट बता दीजिए।
ओके। या
ओके। सो, ऑडियो बिल्कुल सही है गाइस।
ऑडियो इज वेरी क्लियर।
प्लीज लेट मी नो फास्ट।
ऑडियो इज वेरी क्लियर गाइस।
ओके ओके ओके बहुत बढ़िया
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
ओके सो गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू आई होप आप सभी
बढ़िया होंगे अच्छे होंगे मजे में होंगे
नमस्ते नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी
नमस्ते नमस्ते
ओके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
हम
ओके
ओके सो वेलकम एवरीबॉडी टू क्लास एट ऑफ आवर
एसओसी जॉब रेडी एसओसी लाइव फ्री लाइव
ट्रेनिंग एंड सभी को एक बार जुड़ जाना आने
देते हैं। आ जाने देते हैं। तब तक सभी लोग
लाइक ठोक देना। जितने भी प्रेजेंट आ चुके
हैं अभी सभी एक लाइक ठोक देना फटाफट जल्दी
से।
ओके। सो आई होप कि आप सभी एसओसी की
क्लासेस से खुश तो जरूर होंगे। अह क्योंकि
यह जो क्लासेस हैं, काफ़ी रेगुलर हो रही
हैं। काफ़ी अह फ़्रीक्वेंट हो रही हैं।
रेगुलर एंड फ़्रीक्वेंट का मतलब मेरा है कि
जितना गैप देना अ चाहिए, उतना गैप भी मिल
रहा है आपको और जितनी फ्रीक्वेंट ये के
सेशंस आनी चाहिए, उतनी सेशंस फ्रीक्वेंट आ
भी रही हैं। राइट? सारी चीजें आपकी हो रही
हैं। चलिए, तो सभी को आने देते हैं। उसके
पहले मैं आपको कुछ चीजें बता देता हूं।
सबसे पहली चीज राइट?
सबसे पहली चीज बहुत खुश हैं? सब लोग खुश
हैं क्या? सब लोग खुश हैं? मुझे बता
दीजिए। सभी लोग हैप्पीह हैं। लेट मी नो।
ताकि मुझे पता चले ना यार कि इफ एक्चुअली
एवरीवन इज हैप्पी ऑ नॉट। 100 यूज़ेस पूरे
होने देते हैं।
हम
100 यूजर्स को पूरे हो जाने देते हैं। देन
वी विल स्टार्ट। बट उसके पहले मैं यहां पे
आपको कुछ चीजें हैं वो बता देता हूं। पहले
जैसा कि आप सबको पहले से हर सेशन में मैं
बताता हूं कि आपको दो-तीन चीजें हैं जो
करनी ही करनी है। सबसे पहली चीज कि जैसे
ही आप सेशन को ज्वाइन करते हैं लाइक ठोकते
जाइए एकदम बिल्कुल क्योंकि धमाकेदार
लाइक्स से धमाकेदार मजे आते हैं। दूसरी
अगर आप सब्सक्राइब्ड नहीं है डेफ्रोनिक्स
एकडमी से तो सब्सक्राइब प्यारा सा
सब्सक्राइब का बटन है। क्लिक कर दीजिए। ऑल
नोटिफिकेशन जरूर इनेबल कीजिएगा ऑल करके
ताकि नोटिफिकेशन आपको मिल जाए। तीसरी चीज
है किसी भी लाइव सेक्शन में जाके किसी भी
एसओसी की क्लास कोई सी भी क्लास 7 6 5 4 8
9 या जो भी क्लासेस होंगी उस पे
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाके आपको दो लिंक्स
मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का लिंक
मिलेगा और एक WhatsApp चैनल मिलेगा। एसओसी
का यह स्पेसिफिक जो है ना आपको ग्रुप
मिलेगा। इस ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा।
सारी एसओसी से रिलेटेड नोट्स, रिसोर्सेज,
अपकमिंग जो इसके रिगार्डिंग सर्टिफिकेशन
होगी इस कोर्स के एंड के बाद वो इंटरव्यू
के क्वेश्चंस या व्हाटएवर रिसोर्सेज आर
देयर दैट वी हैव टू प्रोवाइड वी विल
प्रोवाइड इन दिस ग्रुप ओनली। नेक्स्ट ये
है WhatsApp चैनल जिस पे 11,000
डिफरोंस्टर्स हमारे साथ जुड़े हैं। इस पे
आप हमें फॉलो कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि WhatsApp
चैनल पे आपको सबसे पहले कोई भी अपडेट मिल
जाती है। सबसे पहले कहीं से भी पहले सबसे
पहले आपको WhatsApp पे अपडेट मिलेगा चैनल
पे। तो इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। बस ये मेन
वर्क आपका ये है। उसके बाद आप हमारा एक्स
पेज है एक्स हैंडल है डिफ्रॉनिक्स का
x.com dfonic academy इसको फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। यहां अपकमिंग कुछ टाइम आपको
अलग-अलग तरह के अपडेट्स एंड चीजें मिलने
मिलेंगी देखने को। ये Lindin पेज है।
बेसिकली मेरा Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप इस
पे आके मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं, फॉलो कर
सकते हैं फॉर डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ अपडेट्स।
यह हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का Instagram
पेज है। यहां लगभग 50 के जो
डिफ्रॉनिक्सर्स हैं। यहां पे इनफेटिव
रील्स एंड कंटेंट्स के लिए आप यहां पे आके
हमें फॉलो कर सकते हैं। ये हमारी वेबसाइट
है। यहां हमारा नंबर दिया हुआ है। इस नंबर
पे हमें कांटेक्ट करके WhatsApp पे किसी
भी तरह की इंफॉर्मेशनेशन क्वेरीज या कुछ
भी आपके मन में हो उस चीज को आप यहां पे
पूछ सकते हैं। दैट्स इट। ये सारे काम आपको
कर लेने हैं। अब
बिफोर आई स्टार्ट टुडेेस सेशन आई वांट टू
आस्क यू गाइस अ वेरीेंट थिंग्स अ दैट इज अ
दैट शुड बी आंसर्ड बाय एवरीबडी प्रेजेंट
हियर वाचिंग दिस पर्टिकुलर एसओसी सेशंस।
देखो जब मैंने एसओसी की क्लासेस स्टार्ट
करी थी तो मुझे बहुत सारी एक्सपेक्टेशंस
रही हैं। जैसे ही मैंने स्टार्ट करी थी ये
ट्रेनिंग आप लोगों से एक्सपेक्टेशंस रही
हैं। मैंने ये सोचा था कई लोग ऐसे होते
हैं ना कि
फ्री में है तो कुछ भी पढ़ा रहे हैं, कुछ
भी दे रहे हैं। तो मेरा जो थॉट प्रोसेस था
कि मैं आपको फ्री में उस लेवल की ट्रेनिंग
दूं जो आपको जॉब रेडी बनाए। एसओसी एल1
पोजीशन के लिए एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए। एंड
मेरे को यह एक्सपेक्टेशंस थी कि आपसे
मैं
एक छोटी सी उम्मीद कर सकूं कि आप कंटिन्यू
इस ट्रेनिंग को फॉलो करेंगे। जैसे और जिस
फ्लो में मैं आपको आगे लेकर जा रहा हूं,
उसी फ्लो में आप आगे जाएंगे। एंड जिस
तरीके से मैं आपको गाइड कर रहा हूं, आप
उसी तरीके से उस गाइडेंस को एक्सेप्ट करते
हुए डेस्टिनेशन तक पहुंचेंगे एंड इस
ट्रेनिंग को एंड करेंगे। उसके बाद हम
इंटरव्यूज के क्वेश्चंस, इंटरव्यू
प्रिपरेशंस, मॉक इंटरव्यूज एंड एवरीथिंग
वी विल बी कवरिंग। देन हमारा फाइनल फेज
स्टार्ट होगा जब आप में से एलिजिबल
स्टूडेंट्स या लर्नर्स जो होंगे उन सभी से
सभी लोग जो हैं वो अप्लाई करेंगे अलग-अलग
रोल्स के लिए। अलग-अलग मतलब कंपनीज़ में।
चलिए
ओके। देयर वाज़ सम इशू हियर। आई थिंक इट
विल बी करेक्टेड सून।
आई होप यू गॉट इट। राइट? आई होप आप समझ गए
होंगे इस चीज को। एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड राइट?
सभी लोग समझ गए इस चीज़ को? मुझे बता दीजिए
एक बार।
एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
एवरीवन गॉट इट?
विजय इज़ आस्किंग सर, हम अभी थ्योरी पढ़ रहे
हैं। क्या हम बाद में प्रैक्टिकल पढ़ेंगे
या नहीं पढ़ेंगे? आपको क्या लगता है? जो
लोग मुझे जानते हैं वो ऑलरेडी समझ गए
होंगे। ऑलरेडी जानते हैं कि हम प्रैक्टिकल
पढ़ेंगे या नहीं पढ़ेंगे? देखो, एक पूरी
ट्रेनिंग है एसओसी की। ठीक है? जो आपको
जॉब रेडी बनाएगी। अब उस जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग
के दौरान अगर प्रैक्टिकल कराना है तो हम
प्रैक्टिकल भी कराएंगे। तो हम प्रैक्टिकल
बिल्कुल करेंगे। और आपको क्या लगता है?
कोई भी ऐसी स्किल आप सीखोगे तो बिना
प्रैक्टिकल के सीख सकते हो क्या? नहीं सीख
सकते ना? या ओनली प्रैक्टिकल से सीख सकते
हो क्या? बिना थ्यरी के नहीं सीख सकते।
थ्यरी एंड प्रैक्टिकल बोथ आर एज
इंपॉर्टेंट।
बोथ आर इक्वलीेंट।
मैं यह बोलूंगा बोथ आर इक्वलीेंट थ्यरी
एंड प्रैक्टिकल दोनों को लेकर चलना है।
अगर आपने एक भी मिस किया तो आप एसओसी तो
मतलब सीख लेंगे एसओसी के कांसेप्ट्स वगैरह
कुछ-कुछ चीजें जान लेंगे बट आप जॉब रेडी
कभी नहीं बन पाएंगे। तो मेरा फोकस सिर्फ
उनके लिए है इस ट्रेनिंग के थ्रू जो
एक्चुअली बिगिनर्स हैं, न्यूक कमर्स हैं,
फाइनल ईयर या प्रीफाइनल ईयर स्टूडेंट्स
हैं जो एसओसी एल1 रोल को एक्सप्लोर करना
चाहते हैं। उस रोल के लिए जाना चाहते हैं।
उस रोल में करियर बनाना चाहते हैं। मेरा
प्राइम फोकस वही है। मेरा फोकस जो ऑलरेडी
एसओसी के बारे में जानते हैं। जो ऑलरेडी
एसओसी प्रोफेशनल्स हैं उन पे बिल्कुल भी
नहीं है इस ट्रेनिंग के थ्रू। एज़ यूजुअल
मैं डायरेक्ट बात करता हूं और मैं यह पहले
भी बोल चुका हूं। अगेन बोल रहा हूं। ठीक
है? तो प्लीज जो बिगिनर्स हैं जो न्यू
कमर्स हैं आप फ्लो के साथ चलिए। कोई और
कुछ भी आपको बोल रहा हो डोंट केयर अबाउट
दैट। डोंट फोकस ऑन दैट। डोंट थिंक अबाउट
दैट। जस्ट थिंक अबाउट व्हाट आई एम सेइंग।
जस्ट फॉलो व्हाट आई एम डूइंग एंड जस्ट डू
व्हाटएवर आई एम सेइंग। दैट्स इट। एंड यू
विल बी जॉब रेडी। मैं इतनी गारंटी आपको दे
सकता हूं। अब इससे ज्यादा मैं क्या
बोलूंगा? फ्री में आपको चीजें जो मिल रही
है इस लेवल की। इससे ज्यादा मैं आपको कुछ
बोल भी नहीं सकता। राइट?
ठीक है।
ओके। चलिए तो आप लोगों को वीडियो ऑडियो
में कोई इशू तो नहीं आ रही है? मुझे एक
बार बता दीजिए। वीडियो में तो कोई इशू
नहीं आ रही है क्योंकि मेरे साइड बिल्कुल
सही है।
चलिए।
चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात है। नाउ लेट्स
स्टार्ट।
आज के जो सेशन है मैं सबसे पहले मैंने
आपको पहले ही बोला हुआ है।
आई हैव ऑलरेडी टोल्ड यू गाइस कि मैं सबसे
पहले थ्यरी के कांसेप्ट्स जो भी हैं
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
लाइक व्हाटएवर थ्योरी कांसेप्ट्स आर देयर
दैट आर वेरीेंट दैट आर वेरी वेरीेंट आई
विल कवर दैट फर्स्ट चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए आप
में से कई लोगों को सिर्फ प्रैक्टिकल
प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल करना होता है आई
डोंट केयर अबाउट दैट मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ता है। आप कितनी बार भी बोलेंगे आप में
से कुछ लोग हैं जो समझते नहीं है चीजों को
एंड बार-बार प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल करते
हैं। तो मुझे उससे कोई फर्क एक्चुअली नहीं
पड़ता है। मैं आपको पहले ही बता चुका हूं।
मैं अपने फ्लो के साथ जाऊंगा और जो आपके
लिए जरूरी है वो सब मैं कराऊंगा। अब अगर
ये टॉपिक्स अगर आपको नहीं पता तो आप घंटा
घंटा का एसओसी एल वन नहीं बनेंगे कभी भी।
आप कभी भी एसओसी लेवल वन जॉब रेडी नहीं बन
पाएंगे। मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ लिख के दे
देता हूं। क्योंकि आपको चीजें ही कंसेप्ट
ही नहीं पता है। तो आप क्या ही अलर्ट को
समझेंगे। क्या ही ट्रैक करेंगे आप क्या ही
एस्केलेट करेंगे। जब आपको कांसेप्ट ही
नहीं पता तो आप अलर्ट को नहीं समझ पाएंगे।
जो अलर्ट्स आएंगी एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड्स में
या एसआईएम टूल्स के डैशबोर्ड में आप उन
अलर्ट्स के ऊपर डिस्क्रिप्शन या उसके लॉग
कमेंट्स को लिख नहीं पाएंगे। एग्जैक्टली
आप डिस्क्राइब नहीं कर पाएंगे उसको। आप
डिस्क्राइब एंड समझ नहीं पाएंगे तो आप
उसको एस्केलेट कैसे कर पाएंगे? जब आप उसको
एस्केलेट नहीं कर पाएंगे तो फिर आप एसओसी
क्यों हैं आप एसओसी एल1? L1 का काम ही
होता है एस्केलेशन करना या क्लोज करना जब
अगर लगे कि नहीं कोई इशू नहीं है तो। तो
ये चीजें सीखनी पड़ती है। राइट? एंड मैं
एक चीज़ और बोलूंगा। प्लीज डोंट स्पैम। जो
भी स्पैम करते हैं ना दो-तीन बार बस आप
मैसेज कर दीजिए। छोड़ दीजिए। बार-बार
करेंगे बाकी यूज़र्स को दिक्कत आती है।
यहां पे सर मैं बीसीए फाइनल ईयर स्टूडेंट
हूं। घर से जॉब का प्रेशर है। साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में करियर बनाना है। पर समझ
नहीं आ रहा है कैसे मिलेगी। प्लीज गाइड
करिए। बस आप इसी सीरीज को फॉलो कीजिए। आई
विल जस्ट सजेस्ट इट। दैट्स इट। कि आप इसको
फॉलो करें। दैट्स इट। चलिए
क्या बता सकते हैं थ्योरी में कितना टाइम
इसका कोई टाइमिंग नहीं है कुछ भी नहीं है
विजय मैंने एक टाइमलाइन दिया है थ्री टू
फोर मंथ्स का एप्रोक्समेट टाइमलाइन आपको
कंप्लीट टाइमलाइन दिया है टोटल टाइमलाइन
दिया है थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स का अब उसमें भी
आप सोचेंगे कि मैं आपको थ्योरी का पार्ट
बता दूं कितना टाइम लगेगा प्रैक्टिकल का
बता दूं तो ये तो मुझे भी नहीं पता है
जितनी जो जो चीजें इंपॉर्टेंट है वो मैं
सब कराऊंगा एंड थ्यरी के साथ-साथ
प्रैक्टिकल थ्योरी कराऊंगा फिर जो देखो जब
तक जितनी थ्यरीज़ की रिक्वायरमेंट है उतनी
थ्यरीज़ कराऊंगा। फिर जब प्रैक्टिकल की
रिक्वायर प्रैक्टिकल कराऊंगा। फिर अगेन जब
थ्योरी के बीच में रिक्वायरमेंट है थ्यरी
के साथ प्रैक्टिकल भी कराऊंगा। ये सारी
चीजें होंगी। थोड़ा पेशेंस रखो। फ्लो के
साथ जाओ। प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल ये सब
माइंड में मत डालो। ये चीजें आपके दिमाग
में डाली गई है पहले। बाय फर्जी
इंस्ट्रक्टर्स, फर्जी टीचर्स, फर्जी
इंस्टीटशंस कि भैया प्रैक्टिकल होता है।
सब कुछ प्रैक्टिकल ही है तो बेस्ट है।
इतना हम प्रैक्टिकल कराते हैं। ये सब डाल
के आपके दिमाग को कचरा बना दिया गया। तो
कॉंसेप्ट एंड थ्यरी इज द मोस्टेंट थिंग।
देन वी विल अप्लाई दोज़ कॉनंसेप्ट्स एंड
थ्यरीज़ एंड वी विल मेमोराइज़ दोज़
कॉनंसेप्ट्स एंड थ्यरीज़ व्हेन व्हाइल
डूइंग द प्रैक्टिकल्स। जब आप प्रैक्टिकल
करेंगे तो वही कांसेप्ट्स एंड वही जो आपके
कांसेप्ट्स हैं वो आपको मेमोराइज़ होंगे और
आपको पता चलेगा। अच्छा हां ये हमने पढ़ा था
कि एक डेटा या पैकेट ऐसे मूव करके उधर
जाके ये काम करती है। तो हम प्रैक्टिकल
में भी वही काम हो रहा है। दैट्स द मेन
थिंग ऑफ दैट्स द मेन मोटिव ऑफ़ प्रैक्टिकल।
ठीक है?
चलिए।
ओके नाउ टुडे वी आर गोइंग टू सी पासवर्ड्स
अटैक्स। इसके बारे में हम थोड़ा समझने
वाले हैं। पासवर्ड अटैक्स एंड इसके टाइप्स
किस-किन तरीके से पासवर्ड अटैक्स होते
हैं। एंड इसके नेक्स्ट सेशन में हम
पासवर्ड से ही रिलेटेड अलग और मेथोडोलॉजीस
और अलग चीजें भी देखेंगे। याद रखिएगा आज
का सेशन। एंड मोस्ट प्रोबेब्ली इसके बाद
जो सेशन होंगे वो दोनों लिंक्ड होंगे एक
तरह से। लिंग्ड का मतलब है दोनों एक दूसरे
के पार्ट होंगे। ये फर्स्ट पार्ट हम मान
सकते हैं। नेक्स्ट वाला इसका सेकंड पार्ट
हो सकता है। क्योंकि ये थोड़ा सा ब्रॉड
टॉपिक है। एंड मैं चाहता हूं कि आप इसके
बारे में अच्छे से जाने क्योंकि ये बहुत
ज्यादा मैटर करती है। बहुत ज्यादा एज एन
एसओसी आपका काम है डिफेंड करना। आप फर्स्ट
लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंड है। डिफेंस है। राइट? तो
आपका काम है किसी भी तरह के अटैक से एक
कंपनी को एक इन इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एक
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को एक कंपनी के
नेटवर्क को सेफगार्ड करना। को बचाना। यह
आपका काम। अब उस काम के लिए आपको जो जो
स्किल्स चाहिए वह सब एज एसओसी आपको गेन
करनी होती है। तो एसओसी एक पूरा पैकेज है
जिसमें सिर्फ एक कांसेप्ट और एक टॉपिक पे
फोकस करके या उसकी नॉलेज लेके काम नहीं
चलने वाला है। मल्टीपल चीजें आएंगी जिसमें
कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी के कंटेंट्स इनवॉल्वड
होंगे। नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के इन्वॉल्वड
होंगे। डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स के इनवॉल्वड
होंगे। देयर आर डिफरेंट डिफरेंट थिंग्स आर
देयर। तो हम उन्हीं टॉपिक्स को धीरे-धीरे
कवर करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं क्योंकि
हमारा यह जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग है। तो हम हर
एक चीज को बहुत ही बारीकी से बहुत ही
प्यार से अच्छे से धीरे-धीरे इसको कवर
करेंगे एंड उसको कंप्लीट करेंगे। आप बहुत
टाइम वेस्ट अपना ऑलरेडी कर चुके होते हैं।
बहुत टाइम वेस्ट करते रहते हैं। मुझे 3 से
4 महीने 4 1/2 महीने का टाइम दे दीजिए।
एंड बस बस आप ट्रस्ट कीजिए जो चीजें चल
रही हैं जो चीजें मैं बता रहा हूं। इन
चीजों को अप्लाई कीजिएगा। जब आप कंप्लीट
कर लेंगे इस ट्रेनिंग को। जब आप इंटरव्यू
देने जाएंगे जब आप अप्लाई करेंगे जब आपका
इंटरव्यू हो रहा होगा। इन्हीं नॉलेज को
अप्लाई कीजिएगा। एंड मैं आपको गारंटी देता
हूं कि सक्सेस रेशियो 99% होने वाली है।
अगर आपने इसको प्रॉपर्ली फॉलो किया है
जैसे मैंने बताया जैसे करा है। एंड
सिंसियरली फॉलो किया है। 1% मैं क्यों हटा
रहा हूं? क्योंकि 100% अगर मैं बोल दूंगा
तो यहीं पे फिर फर्जीवाड़ा हो जाता है कि
डिफ्रॉनिक्स इज़ सेइंग 100% एसोसिएट
रिजल्ट। ये तो होता ही नहीं है। 100%
नोबडी कैन अचीव। चलिए
अब पासवर्ड अटैक्स में देयर आर डिफरेंट
काइंड ऑफ़ पासवर्ड अटैक्स। पासवर्ड अटैक्स
का मतलब है कि पासवर्ड को गैब करने का या
पासवर्ड जानने का, पासवर्ड रिट्राइव करने
का डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ अप्रोचेस। अब अटैकर्स
जो होते हैं वो डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ अप्रोचेस
यूज़ करते हैं। टू ब्रीच पासवर्ड्स, टू गेस
द पासवर्ड्स, टू गेट द पासवर्ड्स एंड
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ़ थिंग्स। उसमें
सबसे पहला सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट एंड सबसे
ज्यादा वाइडली यूज़्ड एक अटैक मेथड होता है
जिसको हम बोलते हैं ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। वी
नो दिस एज ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। आप में से
मुझे यकीन है कि मुझे लगता है आउट ऑफ 100
90 पीपल मस्ट बी नोइंग अबाउट दिस टर्म
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। कम से कम टर्म तो पता
होगा। तो मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार चैट में।
आप में से कितने लोगों को ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक। ये टर्म या इसके बारे में पता पहले
से था। मैं आपको और भी डिटेल बताऊंगा बट
स्टिल आप मुझे बताइए हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू
वर नोइंग बता दीजिए
हम
ओके। कई लोगों को पता है ऑलरेडी बट आपको
मैं आज कुछ ऐसी चीजें बताऊंगा जो आपको
पहले नहीं पता होंगी। आज मैं आपको कुछ ऐसी
चीजें बताऊंगा जो आपको पहले नहीं पता
होंगी। आपको चीजें पता है, टर्म्स पता है
सब कुछ ब्रूट फ़ोर्स के बारे में पता होगा।
बट आज जो चीजें पता चलेंगी वो आपको शायद
पहले ना हो पता हो। देखो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
क्या होता है? अ ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक इज़
व्हेन एन अटैकर ट्राइज़ मेनी पासवर्ड
कॉम्बिनेशंस रिपीटेडली अंटिल द करेक्ट वन
वर्क्स। अटैकर ट्राई एव्री पॉसिबल पासवर्ड
कॉम्बिनेशन अंटिल वन वक्स। इसका मतलब
ब्रूट फोर्स एक टेक्निक है। देखो ब्रूट
फोर्स कुछ नहीं। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स जस्ट अ
टेक्निक। कोई भी ऐसी पासवर्ड
चुराने की टेक्निक।
किसी भी तरह का अटैक जहां पर एक अटैकर
बहुत सारे पॉसिबल पासवर्ड कॉम्बिनेशन का
यूज करता है
एक सिंगल यूजर के ऊपर जब तक उसको सही
पासवर्ड नहीं मिल जाते अंटिल दे गेट्स द
करेक्ट पासवर्ड
तो अब जैसे एक यूजर है सैम अब सैम के
विंडोज की पासवर्ड को रूट फोर्स करना है
अब एक अटैकर ने
1 करोड़ पासवर्ड्स का कॉम्बिनेशन का एक
डेटाबेस बना लिया, स्टोर कर लिया। एक
स्क्रिप्ट चला दी और Windows लॉग इन
स्क्रीन पर लेट्स सपोज देयर इज़ नो रेट
लिमिट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग। इमेजिन कर लो। उस वो
1 करोड़ पासवर्ड्स कॉम्बिनेशंस को एक-एक
करके ट्राई कर रहा है। अब उसमें से बाय
चांस कोई एक ऐसी पासवर्ड हो सकती है जो
एक्चुअली सैम की ओरिजिनल पासवर्ड होगी।
जैसे ही वो पासवर्ड मिलेगी उस कॉम्बिनेशन
जब वो स्क्रिप्ट चल रही है उस कॉम्बिनेशंस
के लिए वैसे ही वो लॉग इन सक्सेसफुल हो
जाएगा एंड वो पासवर्ड बता दिया जाएगा कि
ये पासवर्ड करेक्ट पासवर्ड है। दिस इज़
कॉल्ड ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। इसमें सिंपल
अटैकर ट्राई करता है फिर फेल होता है। फिर
ट्राई करता है, फिर से फेल होता है। फिर
से ट्राई करता है, फिर से फेल होता है।
अरे फिर से ट्राई करेगा, फिर फेल होगा बट
एक बार ट्राई करेगा तो सक्सेस उसको मिल ही
जाएगी।
अब इसके बारे में इंटरेस्टिंग चीज़
बताऊंगा। पहले देख लेते हैं कैसे ये वर्क
करता है। अटैकर टारगेट्स लॉग इन पोर्टल्स।
अटैकर्स जनरली क्या करते हैं ना इस तरह के
अटैक में लॉग इन पोर्टल्स को टारगेट करते
हैं। अब लॉग इन पोर्टल्स क्या होता है?
जैसे वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस पर हो सकते हैं।
लॉग इन पैनल्स वगैरह हो सकते हैं।
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल आरडीपीस के
लॉगिन क्रेडेंशियल्स हो सकते हैं। वीपीए
वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क जो वीpए वीपीएस
वगैरह यूज़ करते हैं आप उसके लॉग इन
पोर्टल्स हो सकते हैं। किसी सिस्टम का
लॉगिन पोर्टल हो सकता है। किसी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का लॉग इन पोर्टल हो सकता है। देयर
कैन बी एनी काइंड ऑफ़ लॉग इन पोर्टल। किसी
राउटर का लॉग इन पोर्टल हो सकता है। ठीक
है? किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन पे कोई स्पेसिफिक
फंक्शनैलिटीज है उसका लॉगिन पोर्टल हो
सकता है। कोई एडमिन लॉग इन पोर्टल हो सकता
है। कोई से भी जहां पे यूजरनेम पासवर्ड की
रिक्वायरमेंट हो या जहां पे पासवर्ड्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट हो तो वहां पे उन सब जगहों
को टारगेट किया जाता है। सेंड्स थाउजेंड्स
ऑफ पासवर्ड अटेम्प्ट्स। थाउजेंड्स ही नहीं
लैक्स ऑफ लैक्स ऑफ नहीं
करोड़ ऑफ पासवर्ड अटेम्प्ट्स वहां पे किए
जाते हैं। इफ नो अकाउंट लॉकउ इवेंचुअली
सक्सेस। अब वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस या इस तरह
के जो भी प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं उनमें एक
सेफ्टी अ जो मेजर है वो यूज़ किया जाता है।
एक डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म यूज़ किया जाता है
अकाउंट लॉकआउट का या फिर आईपी एड्रेस
ब्लैक लिस्ट का या फिर रेट लिमिटिंग का।
अब ऐसे अटैक्स से बचने के लिए वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस या जो भी ऐसे एप्लीकेशनेशंस
हैं जिस पे अटैक किया जाता है अटैकर के
द्वारा उन लोगों की तरफ से एक डिफेंस
मैकेनिज्म यूज़ की जाती है। उस डिफेंस
मैकेनिज्म में वो अकाउंट लॉकआउट भी रख
सकते हैं। जैसे कोई अटैकर स्पेसिफिक
अकाउंट के थ्रू कोई अटेम्प्ट कर रहा है
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स का तो अकाउंट को लॉक कर दिया
जाएगा या उस पर्टिकुलर आईपी को ब्लैक
लिस्ट कर दी जाएगी। उस आईपी से वो कर ही
ना पाए इस तरह के अटैक या फिर एट द एंड
क्या होगा कि हो सकता है पॉसिबल है कि
आपको अलग-अलग तरह के जो है ब्लैक ब्लैक
लिस्ट करने के तरीके देखने को मिल जाए या
अलग-अलग तरह के वहां पे आपको स्टॉप करने
के जैसे उसमें से एक रेट लिमिटिंग आती है
यानी कि एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम फ्रेम में आप
कितने रिक्वेस्ट भेज सकते हो एक वेब
एप्लीकेशन को उस पे लिमिट लगाना है। अब
बहुत सारे सर्वर्स 1 मिनट में सिर् 15 से
20 रिक्वेस्ट्स को एक्सेप्ट करते हैं।
जैसे ही 1 मिनट के अंदर 15 20 रिक्वेस्ट
के ऊपर अगर सेम आईपी से रिक्वेस्ट जा रही
है या इवन मल्टीपल आईपी से भी जा रही है
वो उस रिक्वेस्ट को ड्रॉप कर देते हैं।
यानी कि उस रिक्वेस्ट को फुलफिल ही नहीं
करेंगे। अब कोई क्लाइंट सर्वर को
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा है तो सर्वर को अगर 1
मिनट में 20 से ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट आ गई तो
सर्वर बोलेगा तुम चाहे कोई भी क्यों ना हो
ड्रॉप खत्म। आई डोंट वांट टू फुलफिल योर
रिक्वेस्ट। सर्वर का काम होता है
रिक्वेस्ट फुलफिल करना बट यहां पर रेट
लिमिट के कारण वह फुलफिल नहीं करेगा। तो
यह डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म है। तो अब डिफेंस
मैकेनिज्म पे तो हम बाद में आते हैं। अब
यहां पे हमारा मेन मोटिव है ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक को समझना। तो अटैकर तब तक ट्राई करता
है अगर बाय चांस इन मैकेनिज्म डिफेंस
मैकेनिज्म को बाईपास कर लेता है या ये
डिफेंस मैकेनिज्म प्रेजेंट नहीं रहते हैं।
तो वहां पे ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक के सक्सेस
होने के चांसेस हो जाते हैं 100%। अब
दुनिया का कोई ऐसा पासवर्ड नहीं बना है जो
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक से ब्रेक ना किया जा
सके। लिटरली मैं आपको लिटरली बोल रहा हूं
दुनिया का
सॉरी कोई भी ऐसा पासवर्ड नहीं बना है या
कोई भी ऐसा सिस्टम दुनिया में इतना
सिक्योर नहीं है कि वो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
से बच सके।
गिवन कि हम उतना टाइम दे रहे हैं। हमारे
पास उतनी कंप्यूटिंग रिसोर्सेज हैं और
हमारे पास उस लेवल की एक वर्ड लिस्ट है।
तो आप दुनिया का कोई भी पासवर्ड क्रैक कर
सकते हैं ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक के थ्रू।
इमेजिन करिए। आंख जब मैं इमेजिन करने को
बोलूं तो आंखें बंद कर लीजिए। ऐसे आंखों
को बंद कर लीजिए। और मैं बोलूं तो उसको
सोचिएगा।
जस्ट थिंग इमेजिन करो। कि आपने एक सिस्टम
पर बहुत लॉन्ग 20 लेटर्स का पासवर्ड सेट
किया। 20
अब उसमें आपने
लोअर अल्फाबेट्स, अपर अल्फाबेट्स,
सिंबल्स, स्पेशल कररेक्टर्स, स्पेसेस,
नंबर्स, एवरीथिंग। यू हैव यूज़्ड एव्री
पॉसिबल कररेक्टर्स टू मेक इट मोस्ट
कॉम्प्लेक्स पासवर्ड। एंड उसी तरह का एक
उसी तरह का एक वर्ड लिस्ट अगर अटैकर ने
बना लिया जैसा आपने पासवर्ड रखा है कुछ
उसी तरीके के कॉम्बिनेशंस उसने सेट कर लिए
तो आपका वो पासवर्ड जो है ना वो ज्यादा
टाइम तक उस कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी को डिफेंड नहीं
कर पाएगा। आपकी पासवर्ड आराम से ब्रेक हो
सकती है ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक के थ्रू। अगर
कोई अटैकर एक कॉम्प्लेक्स पासवर्ड के लिए
10 साल तक ब्रूट फ़ोर्स करता रह जाए।
तो वह ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकता है उसको। हां,
उतनी कंप्यूटिंग रिसोर्सेज होनी चाहिए।
उतनी कंप्यूटिंग रिसोर्सेज यूटिलाइज
होंगी, उतनी पावरफुल मशीनंस होनी चाहिए।
उतनी तगड़ी वर्ड लिस्ट होनी चाहिए। अब वर्ड
लिस्ट का मतलब है कि एक ऐसी लिस्ट जिसमें
पॉसिबल पासवर्ड्स के कॉम्बिनेशंस होते
हैं। मल्टीपल कॉम्बिनेशंस ऑफ पासवर्ड्स।
अब यह जो पासवर्ड्स हैं, यह बनाए जाते
हैं। कुछ ऑटोमेटेड बनते हैं। कुछ मैनुअल
कस्टम पासवर्ड्स की लिस्ट बनाई जाती है जो
आप अलग-अलग पैटर्न के थ्रू बना सकते हैं।
बिल्कुल।
राइट? अब मैं आपको बता देता हूं यहां पे
इफ आई शो यू।
सो एवरीवन नो अबाउट काली ललिनक्स?
प्लीज लेट मी नो। इफ यू नो अबाउट काली
लinक्स। आप में से काली लनिक्स के बारे
में सब लोग जानते हैं क्या?
बताइए मुझे
ओके।
चलिए काफी लोग काल काफी लोग कालक्स के
बारे में जानते हैं। अच्छी बात है। मोस्ट
ऑफ यू नो अबाउट का्स।
अभी मैंने काली लinक्स को मैं अभी फिलहाल
के लिए Linux को ऑन कर रहा हूं। स्विच ऑन
कर रहा हूं। ठीक है? आई एम जस्ट
स्टार्टिंग द काल लinक्स। मैं आपको कुछ
चीज़ दिखाता हूं। जैसे कालinx में मैंने
आपको बताया ना कि आप वर्ड लिस्ट जो है बना
सकते हैं खुद का। कालिनेक्स में एक
यूटिलिटी होती है।
कालीनेक्स में एक यूटिलिटी होती है। उसका
नाम होता है क्रंच। क्रंच। ये एक टूल होता
है। कालीनेस के अंदर में आपका इनबिल्ट टूल
आता है। आप क्रंच की हेल्प से अपने खुद के
कस्टम पासवर्ड लिस्ट या वार्ड लिस्ट बना
सकते हैं। फॉर ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। यू कैन
जनरेट योर ओन पासवर्ड लिस्ट। अब यहां पे
इसका एक सिंटेक्स है। उसके थ्रू ये काम
करता है। मैं अगर आपको
मैनुअल इसका दिखाऊं क्रंच का तो आपको
मैनुअल में यहां पे देखने को मिलेगा। अ
इसको यूज़ कैसे करते हैं? क्रंच आपको पहले
टाइप करना होता है। देन आपको मिनिमम लेंथ
बतानी होती है पासवर्ड की। देन मैक्सिमम
लेंथ पासवर्ड का बताना होता है। देन यहां
पे कैसेट स्ट्रिंग अगर कोई है तो आप यूज़
कर सकते हैं। एंड देन यहां पे जो भी आपके
ऑप्शंस हैं जो यहां पे ये ऑप्शंस अलग-अलग
दे रखे हैं ये ऑप्शंस जो है आप यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। अब ये कैशेट स्ट्रिंग्स क्या
होते हैं? तो देखो मैं आपको यहां पे दिखा
देता हूं। जैसे कि
ये
यू मे स्पेसिफाई कैरेक्टर सेट्स फॉर क्रंच
टू यूज़ ऑन द कमांड लाइन। और इफ यू लीव इट
ब्लैंक क्रंच विल यूज़ द डिफ़ॉल्ट कैरेक्टर
सेट्स। ठीक है? अब यह जो कररेक्टर सेट्स
होते हैं, यह काली के अंदर एक फाइल होती
है। कैसेट लिस्ट की फाइल होती है। उस फाइल
से यह कररेक्टर्स को लेता है और उसी के
बेस पे पासवर्ड्स जनरेट करके आपको दे देता
है। अब इसमें अलग-अलग नंबर्स हैं। जैसे
कितने साइज की रखनी है यहां पे कितने
लाइंस की रखनी है यहां पे। फिर आपका कैसेट
लिस्ट का जो पाथ है उसको डिफाइन करना hन f
से देन आप इसमें लाइक आउटपुट्स को इनवर्ट
करना चाहते हैं वो ऑप्शंस यहां पे हो जाता
है अलग-अलग फिर आउटपुट के लिए हफन ओ हफन ओ
का यूज़ करना होता है देन अलग-अलग थिंग्स
आर राइट देयर आर ऑप्शंस दैट यू कैन यूज़
देन आप यहां पे एक रिप्लेसमेंट पैटर्न
रिप्लेसमेंट का भी ऑप्शन मिलता है जैसे इस
तरीके से हफन T का यूज़ करके आप कर सकते
हैं तो यहां पे @ यूज़ करेंगे तो यह लोअर
केस कररेक्टर्स को इंसर्ट करने के लिए एक
पर्टिकुलर प्लेस पे यूज़ में लिया जाता है।
कॉमा इंसर्ट करेंगे तो अपपर केस के लिए
यूज़ में लिया जाता है। परसेंट को यहां पे
नंबर्स के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। एंड
ये जो बेसिकली कैप है अ इसको लिया जाता है
सिंबल्स के लिए। ठीक है? तो इस तरीके के
पैटर्न्स को भी आप अप्लाई कर सकते हैं। अब
यहां पे मैं अगर देखूं मैं आपको यहां पे
सिंपल अ दिखाऊं कैसेट लिस्ट का अ दिस वन
कैसेट लिस्ट। ठीक है? तो अब ये कैरेक्टर
सेट की लिस्ट एक प्रोवाइड करेगा आपको। तो
हम कैसेट लिस्ट को एक बार फाइंड करने की
कोशिश कर लेते हैं। सो मैं यहां पे अ लगा
देता हूं व्हिच सॉरी
मैं यहां पे अ कर देता हूं व्हिच
कैसेट डॉट एलएसटी
ओके सॉरी सॉरी यहां पे
ओके मेरा थोड़ा काली हैंग कर रहा है। सो आई
एम एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर दैट।
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी। मैं थोड़ी थोड़ी सी थोड़ी
सी अ हां कप का भी यूज़ आप कर सकते हैं। यू
कैन यूज़ द कप आल्सो। यू कैन देखो एक और
टूल है कप। सी यू डबल पी। मैं वैसे अ कैसे
मैं वैसे यूज़ बोलूंगा आपको कि अ यूज़ द
क्रंच टूल बट एक और इफ यू वांट कप टूल आप
यूज़ कर सकते हो कप गेट हब करके अभी यहां
पे चैट में किसी ने बोला तो यू कैन यूज़
दिस कप टूल बेसिकली ये पासवर्ड प्रोफाइलर
है नॉट आई आई एम नॉट सेइंग कि ये क्रंच की
तरह ज्यादातर काम करेगा बट ये एक पासवर्ड
प्रोफाइलर है कि आप एक स्पेसिफिक एंट्रीज
के स्पेसिफिक रिक्वायरमेंट के अकॉर्डिंग
जो है आप जो है यहां पे पासवर्ड्स को
क्रिएट कर सकते हो। जैसे आपको किसी एक
टारगेट के बारे में कुछ स्पेसिफिक चीजें
पता है। उसकी डेट ऑफ़ बर्थ पता है। उसका
पेट नेम या ऐसे कॉमन नेम कुछ है वो पता है
आपको। उसका टाइटल या वगैरह-वगैरह पता है,
मोबाइल नंबर्स पता हैं। पता है, कुछ
फेवरेट प्लेसेस पता है, फेवरेट डिशेस पता
है या फेवरेट स्पोर्ट्स पर्सन पता है। तो,
आप ऐसी एंट्रीज करके ऐसी आप डिटेल्स
प्रोवाइड करेंगे इस सॉफ्टवेयर को जो कि
गेट पे आपको अवेलेबल मिलता है। तो आपको
उसके बेसिस पे ये पासवर्ड्स की एक लिस्ट
जनरेट करके देगा जो टारगेट स्पेसिफिक
लिस्ट जो है वो होगा। ठीक है?
अब टारगेट स्पेसिफिक होगा। तो टारगेट
स्पेसिफिक जब होगा तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
कि दैट यू कैन यूज़ हियर राइट दैट यू कैन
यूज़ हियर तो मैं यहां पे कैरेक्टर सेट्स
थोड़ा सा मेरा खाली पता नहीं क्या हो रहा
है
थोड़ा सा वो हो रहा है अ कैश सेट डॉट
एलएसटी हम
तो कैशेट एलएसटी का करंट लोकेशन ये है तो
ये यहीं से क्रंच जो है उठाता है
कररेक्टर्स तो मैं क्या करता हूं मैं यहां
पे इसको उसको मैं आपको दिखाता हूं इस फाइल
के अंदर एग्जैक्टली है क्या? सो दिस इज़ द
लोकेशन। मैं विमim से इसको ओपन करता हूं।
एंड यू विल सी दिस फाइल कंटेंस दिस
पर्टिकुलर एंट्रीज। ठीक है? ओके? नहीं
नहीं कोई बात नहीं लोकेट का भी यूज़ करके
कर सकते हैं। कोई देयर आर मल्टीपल कमांड्स
टू फाइंड और लोकेट थिंग्स इन काली या
Linux। तो हमने यहां पे यहां पे सिंपल
क्या किया? लोकेट कमांड का यूज़ करके उस
फाइल को लोकेट किया जो कि इस लोकेशन पे
है। तो इसके अंदर आप देख सकते हैं कि ये
अलग-अलग तरह के कैरेक्टर्स के सेट्स की
लिस्ट है। एंड दैट वी वी कैन यूज़ टू जनरेट
आवर पासवर्ड। जैसे हेक्स लोअर जहां पे
नंबर्स एंड लोअर केसेस अल्फाबेट्स हैं।
हेक्स अपपर नंबर्स एंड अपपर केसेस
अल्फाबेट्स हैं। न्यूममेरिक सिर्फ नंबर्स
हैं। न्यूमेरिक स्पेस नंबर्स के बाद
स्पेससेस हैं। सिंबल्स 14 करके हैं यहां
पे जो कि 14 सिंबल्स को रिप्रेजेंट करते
हैं। सिंबल्स 14 एंड स्पेस यानी 14
सिंबल्स के साथ स्पेस है। सिंबल्स ऑल
जितने भी सिंबल्स हैं वो सारे सिंबल्स
यहां पे यूज़ हो रहे हैं। सिंबल्स ऑल स्पेस
सिंबल्स जितने हैं सारे और स्पेस। देन यू
अल्फा यहां पे आ रहा है अपर केस का अल्फा
जहां पे ए बी सी डी एफ जी एच आई जे के एल
एम अगर आपको ए बी सी डी भी पढ़नी है मान
लो सीखना है तो आप यहां से भी पढ़ सकते हो
ए बी सी डी ई एफ जी एच आई जे के एल एम एन
ओ पी क्यू आर एस टी यू बी डब्ल्यू एक्स
वाई जेड समझ में आ गया ऐसे कोई गाना भी है
बहुत पुराना
अपर अल्फा स्पेस स्पेस दे दिया यहां पे
राइट उसके बाद अपर अल्फा न्यूमेरिक
न्यूमेरिक के साथ स्पेशल सिंबल्स हैं यहां
पे ऑल ऑल है यहां पे ये सब इसमें आप देख
सकते हो कि एक ऐसी कैरेक्टरिस्टिक
कैरेक्टर सेट है ये देखो मिक्स अल्फा
न्यूमेरिक ऑल स्पेस तो सारे अल्फाबेट्स
न्यूमेरिक्स स्पेस अ स्पेस आपके सारे हर
एक चीज को मिक्स करके ये पासवर्ड क्रिएट
कर देगा सोचो कितना खतरनाक कॉम्बिनेशन
होगा अब ये अपर केस के स्पेसिफिक है लोअर
केसेस के स्पेसिफिक है एंड मिक्स केसेस के
स्पेसिफिक है अब ये देखो मिक्स अल्फा
न्यूममेरिक ऑल स्पेस एसv अब इतने डेंजरस
डेंजरस पासवर्ड कॉम्बिनेशंस अगर आपने इसको
यूज़ यूज़ कर लिया। तो आप सोचो कि एक चार या
पांच लेंथ के भी पासवर्ड्स जनरेट कर रहे
हो तो उसकी साइज टेराबाइट्स पेटाबाइट्स
में आएगी। तो आप इतनी बड़ी पासवर्ड लिस्ट
को खुद की जनरेट कर सकते हो। ऐसे टूल्स की
हेल्प से सोचो आपको पासवर्ड लिस्ट वैसे भी
मिल जाएगी। बट स्टिल अब मैं आपको यहां पे
इससे बाहर आ जाता हूं। ये क्रंच का आप यूज़
करके कर सकते हैं। मैं इसको फिलहाल के लिए
बंद कर रहा हूं क्योंकि मुझे अभी इन सब
चीजों पे ये कोई हैकिंग की क्लास तो नहीं
चल रही है। एसओसी की चल रही है। तो मुझे
अभी फिलहाल इस पे कोई अ काम नहीं करना है।
इसके अलावा इसके अलावा देयर इज अ वेबसाइट।
ठीक है? अ मैं यहां पे वर्ड लिस्ट
एसेट नोट। यहां पे एक वर्ड लिस्ट आपको
मिलेगी एसेट नोट के ऊपर में। आप इसको भी
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एसेट नोट्स के
वॉर्ड लिस्ट काफी पॉपुलर होते हैं। आप
यहां पे देखेंगे कि ऑटोमेटिकली जनरेटेड
वर्ड लिस्ट आपको मिलेंगे जो कि अलग-अलग
तरह के सिनेरियोस के लिए मिलेंगे। जैसे कि
यहां पे एचटीटीपी आरकाइव देन यहां पे आपका
स्वैगर फाइल्स रूट्स लार्ज एचटीटीpआरकाइव
में आपके एनजिंग्स http आरकाइव के अलग-अलग
आएंगे। लाइक डायरेक्टरीज़ के आएंगे।
एचटीएमl के आएंगे, पैरामीटर्स के आएंगे।
फिर एचtपीआरकाइव में आपको एक्सप्रेस
फ्लास्क लारावेल इन सबके वॉर्ड लिस्ट मिल
जाएंगे। देन यहां पे सब डोमेनस के भी वर्ड
लिस्ट आपको मिल जाते हैं। देयर आर देयर आर
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट वर्ड लिस्ट यू कैन यूज़
दैट। अगर आप यहां से करते हैं वर्ड लिस्ट
डाउनलोड
इस तरीके से तो आपको अलग-अलग वर्ड लिस्ट
ऑलरेडी मिल जाएंगे Ghub वगैरह के ऊपर में
जहां पे आप इन वर्ड लिस्ट को भी एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं। यहां से भी आप जो है वर्ड
लिस्ट को यूज़ कर सकते हैं। तो देयर आर
मल्टीपल वर्ड लिस्ट दैट यू कैन फाइंड ऑन
ऑनलाइन। इवन यू कैन जनरेट योर ओन यूजिंग
व्हाट यूजिंग क्रंच लाइक टूल और कप सी यू
डबल पी लाइक टूल। ठीक है? ये समझ में आ
गया हो।
आई थिंक यू गॉट इट। इतना समझ में आया सभी
को? मुझे बताइए एक बार। एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड
टिल हियर।
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस।
सभी लोग आंसर करेंगे तो मजा आता है। एंड
फिर मैं आगे बढूंगा।
ओके एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड वेरी गुड चलिए तो
ब्रूटो अटैक कुछ इसी तरीके से काम करती
है। मान लो एक बॉट होता है या एक अटैकर
होता है। क्या करता है? पासवर्ड को गेस
करता है या पासवर्ड कॉम्बिनेशन ट्राई करता
है टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर में टारगेट के
लॉगिन पोर्टल के अगर वह टारगेट का पे गेस
या जो भी ट्राई कर रहा है वो करेक्ट हुआ
तो सक्सेसफुल अदर अगर अदर लेट्स सपोज कि
अगर वो करेक्ट नहीं हुआ तो वापस से वही
सेम प्रोसेस रिपीट हो जाती है। दैट्स द
थिंग खत्म। यही है हमारा ब्रूट। एवरीवन
मस्ट बी अंडरस्टुड।
बहुत अच्छी बात है नमन आपने नोट्स भी बना
लिए।
ठीक है? ये एक बंदा पूछ रहा है हाउ टू
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अ वेबसाइट। यहां पे हैकिंग
मैंने पहले ही बोला यहां पे हैकिंग की
क्लासेस नहीं चल रही है भाई। तो मैं ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स कैसे करते हैं वो तो नहीं बता सकता।
बट अगर आप हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी के
लाइव क्लासेस को अगर आप सच में आपने देखा
होगा या देखते होंगे तो आपको इस चीज के
बारे में पता चल जाएगा। या आप हमारे
डीसीजीएसपी के भी स्टूडेंट हैं कोर्स के
तो भी आपको पता चल जाएगा। डीसीएसपी के हैं
तो भी आपको पता चल जाएगा। ठीक है?
अब यहां पे आते हैं टाइप्स ऑफ
टाइप्स ऑफ़ पासवर्ड अटैक में ये ब्रूटसोर्स
अटैक था। अब इसका एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स देख
लेते हैं। एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स में मैं
Windows lock की भी बात अलग करूंगा और
फायरवॉल अ जो एंड वीpएं है उसकी बाद में
उसकी बात अलग करूंगा। तो आप देखो यहां पे
Windows लॉग्स में यहां पे किस तरीके की
लॉग्स क्रिएट होंगे। यहां पे अ इवेंट आईडी
फेल्ड लॉग इन कुछ इस तरीके की आपको जो है
इंडिकेशंस इंडिकेटर्स जो है वो आपको
मिलेंगे। मल्टीपल अटेम्प्ट्स फ्रॉम सेम
आईपी कुछ इस तरीके के अलर्ट्स मिलेंगे
आपको। सेम यूजरनेम टारगेटेड रिपीटेडली।
कुछ इस तरीके के आपको अलर्ट्स मिलेंगे। जब
आप एसओस इंडिकेटर्स की बात करते हैं फ्रॉड
बूट ब्रूट फ़ोर्स काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक। आप सेम
पासवर्ड को मल्टीपल टाइम हिट करेंगे तो भी
आपको इंडिकेटर अ जो है वो बता देगा कि
भैया यहां पे कुछ तो गड़बड़ है। देयर इज़
सम गड़बड़
इन फायर वीpए क्या होगा? हाई ऑथेंटिकेशन
फेलर्स एंड लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स एट हाई
फ्रीक्वेंसीज। फाइलर्स फायरवॉल या वीpए के
केसेस में होंगे कि ऑथेंटिकेशन की
फेलियर्स रेट बहुत ज्यादा बढ़ जाएगी। जब
भी मतलब ऐसा लगेगा कि अरे यार बहुत ज्यादा
ऑथेंटिकेशन ट्राई हो रहा है और वो फेल हो
रहा है। एंड लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स जो हैं वह
बहुत ज्यादा आपको दिखने लगेंगे। लॉग इन
बार-बार लगेगा कि अरे यार बहुत मल्टीपल
यूज़र्स लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट मार रहे हैं। लॉग
इन करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं। ये ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक का जो है वो सिनेरियो है जहां
पे आपको अलर्ट्स जो है देखने को मिलते
हैं।
अब एग्जांपल में 500 फेल्ड लॉगिस फॉर यूजर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर। यह आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगा कि 500 फेल लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स हुए
हैं फ्रॉम आईपी दिस विद इन 10 मिनट्स। ठीक
है? तो इस तरीके के कुछ आपको एग्जांपल्स
देखने को मिल सकते हैं कि भैया 10 मिनट
में 500 से भी ज्यादा लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स
देखने को मिल रहे हैं इस पर्टिकुलर आईपी
से। तो वहां पे आपका काम होगा उस आईपीस को
उन आईपीस को ब्लैक लिस्ट करना। उन आईपीस
के अगेंस्ट एक्शन लेना। ठीक है? ताकि इस
तरीके की चीजें अगेन ना हो। समझ में आ
गया?
यह आपका था ब्रूट फ़ोर्स का। अब ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स देखो। अब ब्रूट फोर्स में क्या होता
है? ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक जो होते हैं, इसके
भी टाइप्स होते हैं। इफ यू इफ यू विल सी
देखो, अब ब्रूटf में क्या होता है? ब्रूटf
तो ऑटोमेटिकली अपने आप में एक पासवर्ड का
टाइप है कि हां भैया पासवर्ड्स के टाइप
है। ब्रूटf एंड हाइब्रिड एंड ऑल एवरीथिंग।
ब्रूटf के भी अंदर टाइप्स होते हैं।
अब कुछ पासवर्ड्स के अटैक्स के टाइप्स जो
आपको पता होंगे वह ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक के ही
टाइप्स होते हैं। पहला एक तो सिंपल ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक जो अभी आपने देखा ये सिंपल
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। दूसरा होता है डिक्शनरी
अटैक्स। तीसरा होता है हाइब्रिड ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक। चौथा होता है रिवर्स ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक। पांचवा होता है क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग। हम इनको भी जानने वाले हैं। अब
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स जैसे अटैक्स में अलग-अलग तरह
के टूल्स का यूज़ लिया जाता है। जैसे कि एक
बहुत पॉपुलर टूल है हाइड्रा। एक टूल बहुत
पॉपुलर है बब स्वीट एक टूल है मेड्यूसा एक
टूल है एनक्रैक एक टूल है जॉन द रिपर इस
तरह के टूल्स को यूज़ में लिया जाता है अब
ये टूल्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक में काफी हेल्प
करती हैं एंड इन टूल्स की मदद से आप ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक कर सकते हैं। अब यहां पे मैंने
आप लोगों को फाइव टाइप्स ऑफ ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक बताया। अब इनमें से जोज हम अटैक्स
के टाइप्स हैं इन सबको हम डील करने वाले
हैं। इन सबको हम पहले समझने वाले हैं।
सिंपल ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक आपने ऑलरेडी देख
लिया है। अब हम नेक्स्ट आगे की तरफ करते
हैं। एंड इसमें से जो रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक है इसको हम देखते हैं। अब देखो
रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक क्या होता है?
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स का उल्टा। अब इसको समझ लीजिए।
रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा
नहीं स्लाइड। एंड मैं आपसे पूछता हूं। आप
मुझे बताइए चैट में। ब्रूट फोर्स का जो
आपने मतलब समझा रिवर्स ब्रूट फोर्स का
मतलब क्या हो सकता है? मुझे शॉर्ट में
आंसर बताइए चैट के अंदर में। व्हाट डू यू
थिंक रिवर्स रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक कैन
बी?
व्हाट यू थिंक रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
कैन बी? बताइए।
क्या हो सकता है? उल्टा है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
का उल्टा है। बस इतना समझ लीजिए।
इंस्टेड ऑफ़ ट्राइंग मेनी पासवर्ड्स ऑन योर
वन यूजर द अटैकर ट्राई वन कॉमन पासवर्ड
फॉर मेनी यूजर। बिल्कुल सही ऋषु बिल्कुल
सही आंसर दिया ऋषु द रूट करके जो है
उन्होंने एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट आंसर ब्रूटf
में जैसे आप मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स को एक यूजर
पे ट्राई कर रहे हो व्हाट हैपेंस इन
रिवर्स ब्रूटf कि मल्टीपल यूजर्स पे एक ही
पासवर्ड को ट्राई किया जाता है मेनी
पासवर्ड्स फॉर वन यूजर अटैकर यूजज़ वन
पासवर्ड्स फॉर मेनी यूज़र्स। अब इसी चीज को
ना हम पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग भी बोलते हैं। ये
सिमिलर है। देखो इसको बोलते नहीं है।
सिमिलर है पासवर्ड स्प्रइंग अटैक के। अब
मैं पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग अटैक क्या होता है
वो भी बताऊंगा। बट यूजुअली फोकस्ड ऑन वन
नोन वीक पासवर्ड लाइक समर 2025। अब इसमें
यह सिमिलर तो है पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग के। बट
इसमें एक कंडीशन यह मोस्टली की देखी जाती
है कि एक नोन वीक पासवर्ड्स जो है ना उस
पे फोकस्ड ये पूरी की पूरी आपकी वर्ड
लिस्ट होती है। तो रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक में जब हम वर्ड लिस्ट को यूज़ करते
हैं जहां पे हम मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स को यूज़
करते हैं तो उसमें कॉमन पासवर्ड्स के ऊपर
मोस्टली यह वर्ड लिस्ट जो है वो बेस्ड
होती है। कॉमन पासवर्ड्स जैसे समर 2025
जैसे
आलू प्याज वन टू थ्री ऐसे मतलब मल्टीपल
थिंग्स कुछ भी जो मन में आया वो बोल दे
रहा हूं मैं बट आप समझ जाइए फीलिंग्स को
समझिए ठीक है जैसे कि अ समझ रहे हो ना मैं
मैं किन टाइप के कॉमन पासवर्ड्स की बात कर
रहा हूं आप लोग में से कई लोग इसको यूज़
करते हैं। ठीक है? कई लोग कई तरह के
पासवर्ड्स रखते हैं। मैं तो पासवर्ड
देखदेख के मेरा दिमाग हिल जाता है कई बार।
तो मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स आर देयर दैट पीपल
की। दो कॉमन पासवर्ड्स होते हैं जो अपने
क्लोज वंस एंड अपने नोन वंस के साथ में रख
लेते हैं। उनके नंबर्स उनके नाम के बीच का
वो लगा देते हैं। कभी आगे पीछे कुछ-कुछ
लगा देते हैं। उसका पासवर्ड बना देते हैं।
तो ऐसे पासवर्ड नहीं बनाने होते हैं भाई।
ऐसे पासवर्ड जो हैं वो रिवर्स ब्रूटफोर्स
अटैक में तोड़े जा सकते हैं ईजीली।
हां बिल्कुल सही बोला।
अर्पित। अर्पित ने बिल्कुल सही बोला।
अर्पित इज अब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। ऐसे पास से
थोड़ा बच जाओ।
ऑफेन यूज्ड व्हेन अटैकर बिलीव्स कंपनी यूज
प्रेडिक्टेबल पैटर्न। बहुत सारे लोग
प्रेडिक्टबल पैटर्न यूज़ करते हैं। जैसा
मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बोला। तो उस
प्रेडिक्टेबल पैटर्न को ब्रेकडाउन करने का
काम रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक में करते
हैं। जहां पे मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स को यूज़
किया जाता है एक यूजर के अगेंस्ट। अब इसके
बाद आती है आपकी डिक्शनरी अटैक। डिक्शनरी
अटैक बहुत सिंपल सा है। इंस्टेड ऑफ़
ट्राइंग ऑल कॉम्बिनेशंस अटैकर्स यूजज़ अ
वर्ड लिस्ट ऑफ कॉमन पासवर्ड्स जो डिक्शनरी
वर्ड्स होते हैं जनरली या डिक्शनरी वर्ड
का मतलब हो गया कि या तो डिक्शनरी में
आपको उसकी मीनिंग मिल जाएगी या तो बहुत ही
कॉमन पासवर्ड्स होते हैं। कॉमन पासवर्ड्स
का मतलब है जैसे कि पासवर्ड एडमिन वेलकम 1
2 3 इंडिया @ 1 2 3 एडमिन 1 2 3 एडमिन @ 1
2 3 तो जो कॉमन बहुत ही कॉमन पासवर्ड्स
हैं उनका यूज़ करना या डिक्शनरी वर्ड्स का
यूज़ करना। तो अटैकर क्या करता है? बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स कॉम्बिनेशंस यूज़ नहीं करता है
एक पूरी वर्ड लिस्ट का। वर्ड लिस्ट के
अंदर में। वर्ड लिस्ट का मतलब है कलेक्शन
ऑफ पासवर्ड्स। उसको वर्ड लिस्ट बोलते हैं।
ठीक है? सिंपल सा। उसी वर्ड लिस्ट का यहां
पे यूज़ में लिया तो जाएगा बट उसके अंदर
सारे कॉम्बिनेशंस नहीं होंगे। बस कॉमन
पासवर्ड्स होंगे और डिक्शनरी वर्ड्स
होंगे। सिंपल। तो ये डिक्शनरी अटैक कहला
जाता है। एसओसी इंडिकेटर में क्या आएगा?
अटेमप्ट्स फॉलो कॉमन पासवर्ड पैटर्न लॉगिन
अटेमप्ट्स अक्रॉस मेनी सिस्टम्स मॉडरेट
स्पीड अटेम्प्ट्स ये आपके एसोसिएशन
इंडिकेटर्स में आएगा सिंपल सा है तो
मल्टीपल लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स ये तो ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक में होना ही होना है मल्टीपल
लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स फ्रॉम सेम और सम
रिपीटेड आईपी एड्रेस होना ही होना है। तो
ये चीजें आपको एसओसी एज एसओसी एल1 ध्यान
में रखना है। ऐसी कोई सिनेरियो डेवलप हो,
ऐसी कोई अलर्ट आपके एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड पे आए
तो आप समझ लीजिएगा कि एक ब्रूटफोर्स अटैक
आपके दरवाजे पे दस्तक दे रहा है और आपको
उसको उससे आपको प्रिवेंट करना है। जो भी
ये चीजें हैं उसको बचानी है आपको नेटवर्क
को, अपने सिस्टम को, अपने इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
को। राइट?
नहीं भाई, रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक एंड
डिक्शनरी अटैक सेम नहीं है। अरे, कैसे समझ
रहे हो यार? रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक एंड
डिक्शनरी अटैक्स आर नॉट सेम। डिक्शनरी
अटैक में कॉमन पासवर्ड्स
एंड डिक्शनरी वर्ड का यूज़ किया जाता है।
एंड यहां पे मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स को यूज़
किया जाता है। सिंगल मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स को
यूज़ किया जाता है यहां पे। ठीक है? रिवर्स
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक में यहां पे मल्टीपल
पासवर्ड्स को यूज़ तो किया जाता है ऑन अ
यूजर। लेकिन यहां पर यह वन नॉन वीक
पासवर्ड्स के ऊपर बेस्ड होते हैं। एक नॉन
वीक पासवर्ड्स के इर्द-गिर्द अराउंड आपको
ये होते हैं। ये तो इसमें तो कॉमन सारे
पासवर्ड्स कॉमन पासवर्ड्स आपके आ जाएंगे
डिक्शनरी अटैक में। सिंपल सा। अब यहां पे
आते हैं पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग अटैक। पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग अटैक। अब ये थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट
है। इसका कांसेप्ट ये है कि वन पासवर्ड
है। एक पासवर्ड मेनी यूजर्स बस सिंपल। फिर
से पलट दिया थोड़ा हेक पासवर्ड मेनी यूजेस
सिंपल इसको हम पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग जैसा कि
मैंने आपको यहां बताया कि रिवर्स ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स में यहां पे मेनी पासवर्ड्स
फॉर वन यूजर आ रहा है यहां पे कुछ इस
तरीके से यूज़ करके बट यहां पे पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग में यहां पे वन पासवर्ड फॉर
मेनी यूज़र्स यहां पे यूज़ कुछ सिमिलर साउंड
कर रहा है कुछ इसी तरीके का बट कंफ्यूज
नहीं होना है दोनों में डिफरेंस है। अब
यहां पे एक पासवर्ड मल्टीपल यूज़र्स के लिए
यूज़ में लिया जाएगा। अब यहां पे मान लो एक
पासवर्ड है एडमिन। ठीक है? अब इस पे 1000
एक पासवर्ड एडमिन जो है 1000 अटेम्प्ट्स
किए जा रहे हैं। इस तरह का नॉर्मल क्या
होता है? कि एक एडमिन
पासवर्ड को 1000 अटेम्प्ट लिया जाता है।
ये तो नॉर्मल आपका सिनेरियो हो गया। बट अब
पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग में जो अटैकर है वो
क्या करेगा? नॉर्मल सिनेरियो के अगेंस्ट
जाके 1000 यूज़र्स पे एक ही पासवर्ड
अटेम्प्ट करेगा। जैसे वेलकम @ 1 2 3 तो
नॉर्मल सिनेरियोस ब्रूटf में क्या हो जाता
है कि एक आपका यूजर होता है और उस पे
मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स को मल्टीपल अटेम्प्ट्स
में ट्राई किया जाता है। यहां पे क्या हो
जाता है कि एक ही पासवर्ड को मल्टीपल
यूजर्स पे ट्राई किया जाता है। तो यह हो
जाते हैं आपके पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग अटैक।
पासवर्ड स्प्रे आपको समझ में आ रहा है
नॉर्मल ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक में और पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग अटैक में आर यू गेटिंग उसमें
मल्टीपल पासवर्ड्स एक यूजर पे इसमें एक
पासवर्ड मल्टीपल यूज़र्स पे बताइए समझ में
आ रहा है बहुत सिंपल मैंने समझाया यार
बता दीजिए
यहां पे क्या डिस्कशन चल रहे हैं भाई?
यस यू आर राइट बट हैकर्स यूज्ड टू कलेक्ट
डेटा बिफोर ब्रूट फ़ोर्स। वी ऑल नो आजकल
लोग पासवर्ड रखते हैं लाइक नेम प्लस नंबर
दैट सिंपल पैटर्न टू यूज़ यस यस राइट
बिल्कुल सही बात है इस तरह के पैटर्न आज
भी रखे जाते हैं और हैकर्स जो होते हैं जो
अटैकर्स होते हैं ये बिल्कुल सही बात है
कि वो डेटा कलेक्ट करते हैं सबसे पहले जब
ब्रूटफोर्स अटैक होती है तो वो इनेशन
गैदरिंग पहले अच्छे से करते हैं रिकॉनसेंस
अच्छे से करते हैं डेटा इंफॉर्मेशनेशन एज
मच पॉसिबल वो कलेक्ट करते हैं एंड उसी के
अकॉर्डिंग उसी डेटा पे बेस्ड वो अटैक को
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं और उसी डेटा पे बेस्ड
वो अपनी एक वर्ड लिस्ट तैयार करते उसमें
कॉमन पासवर्ड्स भी हो सकते हैं। उसमें
ब्रज्ड पासवर्ड्स की डेटा भी हो सकती हैं।
उसमें इंटरेस्ट बेस्ड पासवर्ड्स की लिस्ट
जैसे कि सामने टारगेट यूजर का किस तरह का
क्या-क्या इंटरेस्ट है या किस तरह का
पैटर्न है उसके बेस पे हो सकती है। उस
सबको कंबाइन करके एक लिस्ट तैयार की जाती
है जो कि एक ऑल इन वन खतरनाक लिस्ट होती
है। राइट? एंड देन दे टारगेट द विक्टिम।
देन दे अटैक द विक्टिम। एंड सिंपल है।
अब इसमें एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स में क्या है?
वन पासवर्ड अटेम्प्ट पर अकाउंट कि मतलब
भैया एक पासवर्ड को हर अकाउंट पे ट्राई
किया जा रहा है। स्प्रेड ओवर मेनी
यूजरनेम्स अलग-अलग यूज़र्स यूजरनेम्स पे
स्प्रेड अप है। अटेमप्ट्स स्पेड ओवर
टाइम्स ओवर टाइम अटेम्प्ट्स अलग-अलग
अटेम्प्ट्स किए जा रहे हैं। नो लॉकआउट
ट्रिगरर्ड। क्योंकि ट्रिगरर्ड लॉकआउट
इसलिए नहीं होगा ट्रिगरर्ड क्योंकि एक ही
पासवर्ड को अलग-अलग यूज़र्स पे ट्राई किया
जा रहा है। ऐसा थोड़ी ना है कि बहुत सारे
पासवर्ड एक ही यूजर पे ट्राई कर रहा है।
तब तो लॉक आउट होने के चांसेस हैं। बट
यहां पे तो पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग हो रही है
ना। तो यहां पे तो अलग-अलग यूज़र्स हैं। उस
पे एक ही पासवर्ड को ट्राई किया जा रहा
है। यानी कि एक यूजर पे ये एक बार ही
ट्राई किया जा रहा है। तो लॉग आउट होने के
भी चांसेस नहीं है। तो दिस पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग इज़ मोर सेफर एंड इज़ मोर लेस मोर
स्टिल्थ यू कैन से मोर स्टिल देन ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स नॉर्मल ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। आप इस चीज
को समझ पा रहे हो? यह मोर स्टिल्थ कैसे
है?
आर यू गेटिंग
या इट कैन बी डेंजरस। बिल्कुल सही बात है।
इट कैन बी डेंजरस।
ओके आई थिंक एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड दिस। तो यह
एसओसी के इंडिकेटर्स है। देखो जब मैं
सेशंस ले रहा हूं और मैं आपको एसओसी के
इंडिकेटर्स बताता हूं। तो ये एसओसी के
इंडिकेटर्स को थोड़ा ध्यान में रखना है
आपको। याद रखिएगा। यू हैव टू अ कीप इन
माइंड दीज़ काइंड ऑफ़ इंडिकेटर्स। क्योंकि
यही आपके अलर्ट्स जो हैं आपको जब आप रियल
लाइफ में चीजों को फेस करेंगे तो आपको इसी
तरह के अलर्ट्स देखने को मिलेंगे अलग-अलग
तरह के। अलग-अलग सिनेरियोज़ में। तो इन
अलर्ट्स के बारे में आपको पता होनी चाहिए
कि अगर कुछ इस तरह का अलर्ट आ रहा है तो
ये इस तरह का अटैक पॉसिबल है और आपको फिर
उसके बारे में आपको लॉक करनी है। उसके
बारे में फिर आपको देखना है कि ट्रू
पॉजिटिव है फॉल्स पॉज क्या है? उसके
अकॉर्डिंग फिर आपको रिस्पॉन्ड करना है। या
तो क्लोज करेंगे आप या तो फिर आप आगे उसको
एस्केलेट कर देंगे। L2 L3 या इंसिडेंट
रिसोंड डीएफआईआर जो भी है। ठीक है? व्हाई
इट वर्क्स? क्यों? ये वर्क क्यों करता है?
मेनी एंप्लाइजज़ यूज़ प्रेडिक्टेबल
कॉर्पोरेट पैटर्न्स। जैसे कंपनी @ 2025 26
वेलकम @ 123 इस तरह का पी @ डबल एस ओ
डब्ल्यू ओ आर डी वन इस तरीके की चीजों को
ये
कंपनी जो है यूज़ करते हैं एंड दैट्स व्हाई
दिस थिंग वर्क्स पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग तो
पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग आपको आई थिंक नई चीज पता
चली होगी पता चली आप लोगों को कुछ नया पता
चला मैंने आपको बोला ना हर सेशन में हर
क्लास में आपको कुछ ना कुछ नया और बहुत
कुछ नया पता चलेगा एंड आपको जब मैं कुछ
चीज नहीं बताऊं या कोई पुरानी चीज भी
बताऊं और आपको थोड़ी बहुत आईडिया पहले से
भी है तब भी आप उसको खुद से भी क्लास के
बाद एक्सप्लोर करेंगे। वापस से वीडियो
देखेंगे वापस से रिवाइज करेंगे। नोट्स
बनाएंगे एंड ये प्रोसेस आप कंप्लीट फॉलो
करते रहेंगे हमेशा।
ठीक है? थैंक यू। चलिए बहुत अच्छा लगा।
काफी लोग जब आप लोग बोलते हैं कि सर काफी
कुछ नया मिला, वर्थ लगता है कंटेंट। तो
काफी मजा आता है सुनके कि अह देयर इज़
समथिंग दैट वी आर प्रोवाइडिंग अह जेनुइनली
कंट्रीब्यूटिंग टू साइबर सिक्योरिटी
कम्युनिटी। एंड फिर भी लोग हमारे कोर्सेज
को पाइरेट करते रहते हैं। बताओ मतलब हम
अभी हमारे स्टूडेंट्स को मैं अ देखता हूं
कि हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को पाइरेट कर देते
हैं। सेल करने लगते हैं थोड़े-थोड़े पैसों
के लिए। इललीगल थिंग्स करते हैं। ऐसी
चीजें करते हैं जो अ जिन मतलब उनके ऊपर हम
एक्शन भी ले सकते हैं। बट मैं सोचता हूं
कि स्टूडेंट्स हैं एंड चीजें ऐसी हैं कि
अगर उनकी करियर की पे बात आ जाएगी फिर भी
कुछ थोड़े पैसों के लिए दे आर दे डू दिस
काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स। जबकि हम इनको फ्री में
इतना कुछ ऑलरेडी प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है पेड कोर्सर्सेस
ट्रेनिंग्स तो रहेंगी रहेंगी। हमारी कंपनी
है ना तो हम फ्री में अगर सब कुछ कर देंगे
तो कंपनी सर्वाइव कैसे करेगी। राइट? सो बट
स्टिल दे डोंट अंडरस्टैंड। तो मैं चाहता
हूं कि आप लोग जितने भी ये कोर्सेज
ट्रेनिंग्स यहां YouTube पे कर रहे हैं वो
टॉप टॉच क्वालिटी के साथ एंड जेन्युइन
कंटेंट के साथ एंड एक्चुअल जो चीजें हैं
वही आप करें। वो चीज समझे एंड पढ़ें। एंड
उसका यूटिलाइज करके आप अपने लाइफ में कुछ
अच्छा करें। करियर में अच्छा अचीव करें।
एक अच्छा आपको करियर मिल जाए। एंड जो लोग
जॉब करना चाहते हैं उनको जॉब मिल जाए। जो
लोग बिज़नेस करना चाहते हैं वो बिज़नेस
सेटअप कर पाए। जो लोग एंटरप्रेन्योरशिप
में बिलीव करते हैं एंड कुछ अपना बनाना
चाहते हैं वो कुछ अपना बना पाए जो लोग
टीचिंग करना चाहते हैं वो टीच कर पाए सिखा
पाए दैट्स इट दैट्स द जेन्युइन थिंग दैट
आई वांट फ्रॉम एवरीबडी हियर इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी फॉर एव्री काइंड ऑफ़
सब डोमेनस इंक्लूडिंग इनाइड द साइबर
सिक्योरिटी
ठीक है।
थैंक यू गौरव। थैंक यू वेरी मच। थैंक यू।
चलिए अब आते हैं यहां पे अ हाइब्रिड अटैक।
हाइब्रिड अटैक पे। अब ये हाइब्रिड अटैक
क्या होता है? कॉम्बिनेशन ऑफ डिक्शनरी
अटैक प्लस वेरिएशंस कस्टमाइज्ड टू टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। इसमें सिंपल यह क्या होता
है कि यह
कॉम्बिनेशन होता है
डिक्शनरी का एंड उसमें कुछ वेरिएशंस किए
जाते हैं। उसका ये कॉम्बिनेशंस होता है।
मतलब डिक्शनरीज वर्ड्स या कॉमन पासवर्ड्स
के साथ कुछ अ सिंबल्स या कुछ पैटर्न्स या
कुछ
आपके
स्पेशल कररेक्टर्स को यूज़ कर लो वो
हाइब्रिड ट्रैक कहलाता है। जैसे कि एक कुछ
इस कंपनी @ 2023 2024 @3 कुछ इस तरीके का
मतलब डिक्शनरी को भी मिला दो और साथ में
कुछ पैटर्न या कुछ स्पेसिफिक स्पेशल
सिंबल्स या व्हाटएवर उन सबको मिला दो। तो
ये क्या हो जाता है? ये एक हाइब्रिड अटैक
कहलाता जाता है। एसोसिएट इंडिकेटर्स में
क्या आएगा? स्लाइट पासवर्ड वेरिएशंस।
अलग-अलग तरह के पासवर्ड वेरिएशंस देखने को
मिलेंगे आपको। टारगेटेड टू कंपनी नेम।
कंपनी नेम पे ज्यादा फोकस्ड ये देखने को
मिल जाता है कई बार। देखो कंपनी नेम के
अलावा भी हो सकता है। इट्स नॉट लाइक दैट
कि सिर्फ कंपनी नेम पे ये टारगेटेड होते
हैं। दैट कैन बी कम डिफरेंट फ्रॉम कंपनीज़
नेम बट कुछ कॉमन पैटर्न आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगा और स्लाइट पासवर्ड वेरिएशंस आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे। जब हाइब्रिड अटैक कुछ
हो रहा है। अब यहां पे इन सब अटैक्स के
डिफरेंस के बाद में अब मैं आपको यह
बोलूंगा लास्ट में कि ये सब बस ये सब बस
टाइप्स हैं। ठीक है? जो आपको समझाने के
लिए बने हैं। इन सब का प्रैक्टिकल
सिनेरियो में कोई मतलब नहीं रहता है।
प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो में ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
ही आपको पता है। आपको वही काम आएगा। और
पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग अटैक जो कि बेसिकली
उल्टा सिंपल सीधा ऑोजिट केस हो जाता है
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स में नॉर्मल ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
सिंपल ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक का वो आपके जनरली
काम आता है। अब उसी के अंदर ना सारी चीजें
आ जाती है। बट थ्योरी और इंटरव्यूस पर्पस
से अगर कोई पूछ दे कि भैया क्या होता है
एडिशनरी अटैक? क्या होता है हाइब्रिड
अटैक? तो आप कहां से जवाब देंगे अगर आपको
नहीं पता यह तो। कांसेप्ट्स तो पता होने
चाहिए। राइट? अब मेरे को मान लो मेरे को
दिल्ली से जयपुर जाना है।
राइट? आई हैव टू गो टू जयपुर फ्रॉम दिल्ली
या जयपुर से या दिल्ली से कोटा कहीं भी
जाना है। तो मैं जयपुर पहुंच जाऊं। यह
मैटर सिर्फ नहीं करता है।
अगर आपसे जयपुर पहुंचने के बाद कोई
क्वेश्चन करने लगे कि भैया आप कैसे आए?
रूट कौन सा था? रास्ते में ये चीजें क्या
कौन-कौन सी पॉपुलर चीजें आई क्या चीजें तो
एक एक परफेक्ट कैंडिडेट उसको कहा जाएगा जब
वो दिल्ली से दिल्ली से जयपुर जा रहा था
उसको पता है कि इसके बारे में क्वेश्चंस
किए जाएंगे तो जब आप एसओसी के कांसेप्ट्स
को समझ रहे हैं एसओसी एनालिस्ट बनने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं उसकी पाथ को समझ रहे हैं
उसका रोड मैप उसके स्किल्स गेन कर रहे हैं
तो आपको पता है कि लास्ट में आपसे
इंटरव्यू में क्वेश्चंस करे जाएंगे तो
आपको अपने को उसी लेवल की प्रिपरेशन भी तो
करानी है ना शुरू से तो आपको पता है जयपुर
में आपसे क्वेश्चंस किए जाएंगे और आप क्या
हुए कि आपने दिल्ली आप दिल्ली दिल्ली बैठे
आपने एक कार कैब बुक करी दिल्ली में और आप
जयपुर सीधा उतर गए। कोई एक्सप्लोरेशन कुछ
भी नहीं। जयपुर में वहां पे जाके कोई पूछा
कि अच्छा बताओ दिल्ली से जब निकले थे तो
कौन-कौन से पॉपुलर ढाबे आपको देखने को
मिले थे। अब कोई स्मार्ट बंदा होगा हर एक
चीज को नोटिस करता जाएगा क्योंकि उससे
क्वेश्चन पूछे जा सकते हैं। हर एक चीज को
मेमोराइज करते जाएगा। एक नोट हर एक चीज का
नोट बना लेगा। एक कॉपी के अंदर एक एक पेज
के ऊपर में और लास्ट में जाके आंसर करेगा।
सामने वाला इंप्रेस हो जाएगा। सेम चीज
आपको एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग में करनी है कि हर
एक चीज जो बताई जा रही है उसके नोट्स
बनाने हैं। उसको कांसेप्ट्स को समझना है।
अपने से भी हर टॉपिक को एक्सप्लोर करना
है। Lindin पे उन टॉपिक्स को उन की
पॉइंट्स को मेंशन करके टैग करना है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स को। एंड जो नोट्स हैं उनको
अपने पास रखना है। हम जो नोट्स प्रोवाइड
कर रहे हैं उस पे कभी बिलीव उस पे कभी भी
सिर्फ उसी पे डिपेंड हो के नहीं रहना है।
नहीं बिलीव तो करना है बट डिपेंड हो के
नहीं रहना है। क्योंकि हम वो कोर्स का हम
ये वो जो रिसोर्सेज या नोट्स है वो कभी भी
देना बंद कर देंगे। फिर आप लाचार हो
जाएंगे। आप क्या हो जाएंगे? आपको लगेगा
अरे अब भाई अब तो हम कहीं के नहीं रहे। ना
इधर के ना उधर के हमारे पास नोट्स ही नहीं
है। ये नोट्स प्रोवाइड नहीं कर रहे हैं।
तो फिर आपको होगी दिक्कत। तो इसलिए नोट्स
आप खुद का बनाया कीजिए। हालांकि हम नोट्स
अभी तो दे रहे हैं बट क्या पता हम बीच में
रोक दें नोट्स देना कुछ टाइम तक ताकि ये
ये देखें कि कितने लोगों ने अपना नोट्स
बनाया। राइट? तो आपको तो रास्ते पे लेके
जाना है ना भाई। अब जबरदस्ती चलो तब या
अपने आप चलो।
ठीक है। गॉट इट।
थैंक यू
सर कैन यू मेक सेशंस इन इंग्लिश हिंदी इज़
नॉट वेरी फमिलियर यहां पे एक यूजर का
रिक्वेस्ट आया है गाइज़ आप लोग भी आंसर
कीजिए इसका दैट इज़
चित्रलेखा करके हैं यूजर इन्होंने कहा है
कि सर कैन यू मेक द कोर्स दिस मेक दिस मेक
सेशंस इन इंग्लिश। हिंदी में यह ज्यादा
फमिलियर नहीं है। तो मैं इसका जो वो है वो
यूजर्स पे छोड़ देता हूं। यूजर्स जो
बोलेंगे वैसा मैं करूंगा। तो व्हाट यू
एक्सक्टली वांट?
हिंदी सही है ना?
ठीक है। बहुत बढ़िया।
चलिए हिंदी के ज्यादा यहां पर वोट्स हैं
तो हिंदी ही हम करेंगे। तो यह हाइब्रिड
अटैक हो गया। अब आ जाते हैं यहां पर रेनबो
टेबल अटैक। अब आ जाते हैं यहां पे रेनबो
टेबल अटैक। अब देखो रेनबो टेबल अटैक क्या
है? कॉम्बिनेशंस ऑफ डिक्शनरी। ये रेनबो
टेबल अटैक में क्या होता है? यह यहां पे
इसको आप भूल जाइएगा। दिस वन इज नॉट द सेम
थिंग। मैं यहां पे इसको डिस्कार्ड कर देता
हूं। रेनबो टेबल अटैक में आ जाते हैं।
देखो
रेनबो टेबल अटैक में क्या होता है? मैं
यहां पर आपको थोड़ा सा
क्लेरिटी के साथ समझाता हूं। ठीक है? इफ
अटैकर स्टील्स डेटाबसेस कंटेनिंग पासवर्ड
हैशेस दे यूज़ प्रीकंप्यू्यूटेड रेनबो
टेबल्स टू रिवर्स हैशेस इंटू प्लेन
टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड्स।
पहली चीज़। ठीक है? ये होता है रेनबो टेबल
अटैक में। अब देखो रेनबो टेबल अटैक में
यहां पे जो चीजें लिखी हुई हैं
कि दे यूज़ प्रीक कंप्यूटेड रेनबो टेबल्स
टू रिवर्स हैज़ इंटू प्लेन टेक्स्ट
पासवर्ड्स। अब इस चीज को ना लेके कंफ्यूज
मत होइएगा। मैं आपको पहले ही बता रहा हूं।
पहली बात पासवर्ड्स जो होते हैं वो स्टोर
होते हैं#श फॉर्मेट में। हैशेस में स्टोर
होते हैं।#श या#श प्लस साल्ट होता है। दैट
इज़ अ डिफरेंट कांसेप्ट। इसी कांसेप्ट की
मैं बात कर रहा था जो आपको मोस्ट
प्रोबेब्ली नेक्स्ट क्लास में देखने को
मिलेगी क्योंकि इसके बिना जो है आपको शायद
ये कांसेप्ट समझ में नहीं आएंगे। ठीक है?
तो पासवर्ड्स जब आप टाइप करते हैं कहीं पे
स्टोर करने के लिए सेव करते हैं। राइट? तो
पासवर्ड्स हैशेस में स्टोर होते हैं।
इंक्रिप्शन अलग टेक्निक है। अलग
कांसेप्ट्स है। हैशिंग अलग कांसेप्ट है।
इंक्रिप्शन टू वे फंक्शन होता है।
इंक्रिप्शन टू वे फंक्शन होता है। यानी कि
आप किसी एक प्लेन टेक्स्ट को इंक्रिप्ट
करके वापस से डिक्रिप्ट करके प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में देख सकते हैं। एक प्लेन
टेक्स्ट है उसको आपने इंक्रिप्ट किया। वो
इंक्रिप्टेड हो गया। अब आप उसको पढ़ नहीं
सकते। देख नहीं सकते क्योंकि वो प्लेन
टेक्स्ट नहीं है और बाद में आप उसको
डिक्रिप्ट करके कीज़ से प्राइवेट पब्लिक
कीज़ से आप वापस से प्लेन टेक्स्ट को
रिट्रीव कर सकते हैं। प्लेन टेक्स्ट को पढ़
सकते हैं। ये टू वे फंक्शन है बाय
डायरेक्शनल। बट हैशिंग जो होता है जहां जो
जिसकी हेल्प से ये पासवर्ड्स को स्टोर
किया जाता है। डेटाबेस या जहां भी स्टोर
किया जाता है। हैशिंग इज़ अ वन वे फंक्शन।
यानी कि एक बार जब आपने हैशिंग कर दी एक
प्लेन टेक्स्ट पे तो वापस से उस हैड्ड
फॉर्मेट को प्लेन टेक्स्ट में कन्वर्ट
नहीं कर सकते। यू कैन नॉट ये एक ऑथेंटिक
और जेन्युइन कांसेप्ट है। समझ लीजिए,
दिमाग में रख लीजिए। इंक्रिप्शन इज़ अ टू
वे फंक्शन। हैशिंग इज़ अ वन वे फंक्शन।
यहां पर जो चीज लिखी हुई है दे यूज प्री
कंप्यू्यूटेड रेनबो टेबल्स टू रिवर्स#शेस
इनू प्लेन टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड। तो यहां पे ये
नहीं है कि ये हैशेस को प्लेन टेक्स्ट में
कन्वर्ट कर दे रहे हैं। ये रिवर्स रिवर्स
का मतलब यहां पे हो रहा है कि एक ऑलरेडी
प्रीम्यू्यूटेड हैश टेबल होती है।
वो हैश टेबल्स होती है उन्हीं पासवर्ड्स
के जो पासवर्ड्स के अगेंस्ट यहां पे अटैक
ल्च किया जा रहा है। अब जैसे जैसे मान लो
मैं इसको वैसे
मान लो
ठीक है मान लो एक पासवर्ड है एडमिन 1 2 3
ठीक है अब इसका जो हैश है वो कुछ इस तरीके
से है
लेट्स सपोज ये इसका हैश है ठीक है ये इसका
हैश
ये इसका हैश है मान
तो एडमिन 1 2 3 का यह हैश ही रहेगा। ठीक
है? अब अगर कोई एक ऐसी टेबल बनाई जाए
जिसको हम रेनबो टेबल कहेंगे। एक ऐसी टेबल
जनरेट की जाए जिसको हम रेनबो टेबल कहेंगे।
तो उस रेनबो टेबल में ये हैश प्रीम्यूटेड
हैश को यूज़ में लिया जाता है। एंड इसी
प्रीकंप्यू्यूटेड हैश के अगेंस्ट में चेक
किया जाता है पासवर्ड के। तो यह#श जिस
पासवर्ड से मैच करेगी जैसे कि यह मैच करती
है एडमिन 1 2 3 तो बता दिया जाएगा कि यह
जो पासवर्ड है इस#श के अगेंस्ट मैच कर रही
है एंड यह पासवर्ड है उसका। बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है। तो कलेक्शन ऑफ प्री
कंप्यू्यू्यू्यूटेड हैशेस को रेनबो टेबल
कहा जाता है। अब यह कंपेरेटिवली काफी
फास्ट होती है जब इस तरह की कोई रेनबो
टेबल को यूज़ में लिया जाता है। क्योंकि
ऑलरेडी हैशड कंप्यूटेशन की गई रहती है
पासवर्ड्स की। तो उनको बस मैच करना होता
है। फटाफट फटाफट मैच कर लेते हैं। भैया
हां ये इसका हैश है। ये इस पासवर्ड का हैश
है। बिल्कुल मैच कर रहा है। यही पासवर्ड
है। एंड पासवर्ड अटैक में यूज़फुल हो जाता
है। तो इसको बोलते हैं#श
रेनबो टेबल अटैक जहां पे एक प्रीम्यूटेड
रेनबो टेबल्स का यूज़ में यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। अब एक टूल आती है पासवर्ड
क्रैकिंग की जो रेनबो टेबल को यूज़ में
करती है जिसका नाम है ओपीएच क्रैक। आप में
से मे बी कई लोगों को पता होगा। कई लोगों
को नहीं भी पता। ओपीएच क्रैक।
अब देखो ओपीए क्रैक एक ऐसी यूटिलिटी है
जिसको आप बेसिकली Windows वगैरह पे आराम
से यूज़ कर सकते हैं। लाइव सीडी से आप इसको
Linux वगैरह में भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
ओपीएच क्रैक इज़ अ फ्री Windows पासवर्ड
क्रैकर बेस्ड ऑन रेनबो टेबल्स। सो मोस्ट
मोस्टली ये Windows बेस्ड एक पासवर्ड
क्रैकिंग टूल है जो कि रन करता है Windows
पे, Linux पे, Mac OS सब पे। ठीक है? इट
इज़ वेरी एफिशिएंट इंप्लीमेंटेशन ऑफ रेनबो
टेबल्स डन बाय द इन्वेंटर्स ऑफ द मेथड।
ठीक है? इट कम्स विद अ ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफ़ेस। अब इसमें क्या होंगे कि ये एलएम
एंड एंटीएलएम हैशेस को क्रैक करने के लिए
स्पेशली बनाए गए हैं। एलएम एंड एंटीएलएम।
ठीक है? एलएम का मतलब लाइन मैनेजर जो होता
है और एनटीएम न्यू टेक्नोलॉजी लाइन मैनेजर
हैशेस जो Windows में यूज़ में ली जाती है
उसको क्रैक एंड के लिए। तो इसमें क्या
होता है ना? इसमें टेबल्स आपको मिलेंगे।
ये जब टेबल्स पे आप क्लिक करोगे यू विल सी
डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ रेनबो टेबल्स ऑल
फ्री एक्सपी टेबल्स तो ये नाम देखो ये नाम
इन्होंने दिया हुआ है इस पे ज्यादा टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है बट इसमें क्या है आप देख
सकते हैं कि एक एक्सपी फ्री स्मॉल टेबल है
जिसमें कि सक्सेस रेट 99.9% है। यहां पे
कैरेक्टर सेट इसका यूज़ में लिया गया है इस
पर्टिकुलर टेबल को जनरेट करने के लिए।
इसके हैशेस को कंप्यूट करने के लिए। तो इस
कैरेक्टर सेट पे पासवर्ड्स को जनरेट किया
गया होगा एंड उनके
हैशेस को कंप्यूट करके एक टेबल बनाई गई
होगी और उन्हीं कंप्यूटेड हैश टेबल को
रेनबो टेबल कहते हैं और उसी को यूज़ करके
पासवर्ड्स अलग-अलग डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
पासवर्ड कॉम्बिनेशंस का यूज़ किया जाएगा टू
क्रैक द पासवर्ड टू डू द ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक। तो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स का ही पार्ट है। तो
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स ही करेंगे बट रेनबूटेबल का
यूज़ करके। उसी तरीके से यहां पे 380 MB का
है। ये 17 GB की एक सारी है। इसमें 700 MB
का है। 7.5GB की है। 7.4GB की है। 11.9GB
की यहां पे है। 8GB की यहां पे है। 2.3
टेराबाइट की भी यहां पे है। सो जस्ट
इमेजिन 2.3 टेराबाइट्स ऑफ रेनबो टेबल्स।
60 GB की है यहां पे जिसमें कि ये खतरनाक
कररेक्टर सेट्स को यूज़ में है। लिया गया
है। ठीक है? तो यहां पे ये प्रोफेशनल में
पूरे हैं यहां पे 2.3
टेराबाइट अगर आपको पूरा करना है बट
अलग-अलग यहां पे आपको देखने को मिलेगा 107
GB में कौन-कौन से कैरेक्टर सेट को यूज़
किया गया है तो ये बहुत कॉम्प्लेक्स
कैरेक्टर सेट्स ये सारे जो कररेक्टर सेट्स
हैं ये काफी कॉम्प्लेक्स कर कैरेक्टर
सेट्स हैं जहां पे आप देख सकते हैं दो
टेराबाइट की ये अकेले vistा 8 एक्सेल
कैरेक्टर ये पासवर्ड की लेंथ आठ है यहां
पे एंड यहां पे आपको 99% का सक्सेस रेशियो
मिलेगा इस रेनबो टेबल को यूज़ करके तो ये
बहुत ही एफिशिएंट्स रेनबो टेबल्स जिसको
यूज़ में लिया जाता है पासवर्ड क्रैक
अटैकिंग में तो ये आपको अभी तक रेनबो टेबल
अटैक समझ में आ गया होगा। आर यू गेटिंग
रेनबो टेबल अटैक समझ में आया आप लोगों को?
बताइए मुझे। सिंपल पासवर्ड की हैस को
कंप्यूट प्रीड पहले से कंप्यूटेड हैसेस को
यूज़ किया जाता है एक टेबल के फॉर्मेट में
जिसको रेनबो टेबल बोलते हैं। एंड
रेनबो टेबल अटैक उसको कहा जाता है। उसके
बाद ब्रूट फ़ोर्स किया जाता है। आर यू
गेटिंग?
थैंक यू इरफान। लव यू फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर।
ठीक है। एसओसी मे नॉट डायरेक्टली सी दिस
बट डीएफआईआर टीम माइट माइट सी ड्यूरिंग द
इन्वेस्टिगेशन। एसओसी हो सकता है एसओसी
वालों को ये चीज ना समझ में आए। ये चीज ना
दिखे मतलब बट जो डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स एंड
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम है वो इसको देख
सकती है। वो इसको फाइंड आउट कर सकती है।
इस तरह के रेनबूटेबल अटैक। ठीक है?
अब आते हैं यहां पे क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग
अटैक। देखो यह भी एक टाइप ऑफ एक वन ऑफ द
टाइप ऑफ ब्रूटोस अटैक यू कैन से
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग। इसमें क्या होता है?
अटैकर्स जो होते हैं प्रीवियसली लीक्ड
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड्स के कॉम्बिनेशन को यूज़
करते हैं। डेटा ब्रचेस के लीक्ड पासवर्ड्स
एंड यूजरनेम्स
का यूज़ ज्यादातर किया जाता है। इसको हम
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग बोलते हैं। सिंपल
यूजर यूसेस सेम पासवर्ड एवरीवेयर। अब मान
लो कि आप एज अ यूजर हो। कई लोगों का यह
प्रैक्टिस होता है कि एक स्ट्रांग
पासवर्ड्स देखो आप में से कई लोग आप लोग
आप लोग हां अलग-अलग हैश एल्गोरिदम यूज़ हो
तो बिल्कुल आप में से भी कई ऐसे यूज़र्स
होंगे ईमानदारी से ऑनेस्टली बताना जो आप
में से एक पासवर्ड को एक या दो पासवर्ड या
तीन पासवर्ड को सेट कर लेते हैं उसको याद
कर लेते हैं थोड़ा कॉम्प्लेक्स भी हो सकता
है वो ऐसा नहीं है कि बहुत ईजी पासवर्ड ही
आपका होगा आप हो सकता है कॉम्प्लेक्स
पासवर्ड ही रखते होंगे छह सात डिजिट का 10
डिजिट का भी होता होगा आपको याद हो जाता
हो दो-तीन पासवर्ड्स ही होते होंगे और उसी
उसी को आप हर जगह मोस्टली यूज करते होंगे।
आप में से कई लोग ऐसा करते हैं। ईमानदारी
से ऑनेस्टली जवाब देना।
ठीक है? हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू डू दिस काइंड ऑफ़
वर्क?
मेनी ऑफ यू माइट बी डूइंग? आई थिंक कई लोग
करते होंगे। राइट? ये जो प्रैक्टिस है, ये
कुछ खास अच्छी प्रैक्टिस है नहीं। दिस शुड
नॉट बी हैपनिंग मेरे ख्याल से। क्योंकि
अगर आपका एक पासवर्ड कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है
तो आपके मल्टीपल प्लेटफॉर्म्स कंप्रोमाइज
हो जाएंगे। मल्टीपल लॉग इन पोर्टल्स
कंप्रोमाइज हो जाएंगे और डाटा ब्रीचेस में
इस तरह के डेटा ब्रीचेस से इस तरीके की
चीजें पॉसिबल है। जैसे आपने कोई ऐसी कोई
कंपनी की डेटा ब्रीच हुई जिस पे आपको बहुत
ट्रस्ट था और आपने वहां पे वही पासवर्ड
यूज़ किया जो आप बाकी के जगह पे जैसे
ईमेल्स में यूज़ कर रहे हैं। बैंकिंग के
पोर्टल्स पे यूज़ कर रहे हैं या अलग-अलग
लॉग इन पोर्टल्स पे यूज़ कर रहे हैं। तो
आपका वो सब ब्रीच हो जाएगा। इफ वन वेबसाइट
गेट्स ब्रच्ड अटैकर टेस्ट सेम
क्रेडेंशियल्स ऑन ईमेल डोमेनस, बैंकिंग
डोमेनस, वीपीए डोमेनस एंड कॉर्पोरेट लॉगिस
डोमेनस। तो हर जगह पे यूज़ होगा। तो ये
बहुत डेंजरस चीज है। सो प्लीज इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट। दो-तीन चीजें आप ध्यान रखिए।
जब भी आप पासवर्ड यूज़ कीजिए। सबसे पहले तो
आपका पासवर्ड लेंथ में बड़ा होना चाहिए
थोड़ा। दो-तीन डिजिट्स या आप फोर डिजिट का
तो बिल्कुल नहीं होना चाहिए। ताकि थोड़ी
एफर्ट तो लगे अटैकर की। दूसरा मल्टीपल
कैरेक्टर सेट्स का यूज होना चाहिए।
कररेक्टर सेट्स का मतलब लोअर केस
अल्फाबेट, अप्पर केस अल्फाबेट, नंबर्स,
स्पेशल कररेक्टर्स, स्पेसेस, मोर स्पेशल
कररेक्टर्स ऐसे सब यूज़ होने चाहिए। किसी
पैटर्न पे नहीं होना चाहिए। किसी
पर्टिकुलर नाम या किसी नाम नंबर मिला के
या डेट ऑफ़ बर्थ मिला के इस तरह की चीजें
गेसेबल नहीं होना चाहिए ज्यादा कि कोई
आपको प्रोफाइलिंग करे कप जैसे टूल से सीयू
डबल पी जो गेटअप पे मैंने टूल बताया वैसे
टूल से अगर कोई प्रोफाइलिंग करे तो उसको
कंफ्यूजन हो जाए वो उससे प्रोफाइल ना कर
पाए आपके पासवर्ड लिस्ट को वो नहीं होना
चाहिए एंड द मोस्ट
इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग कि आपके रिपीटेड
पासवर्ड्स यूज़ नहीं करने हैं हर जगह पे एक
ही पासवर्ड या दो तीन पासवर्ड्स को ही हर
जगह यूज़ नहीं करना। अलग-अलग जगह पे जो
आपके ज्यादा सेंसिटिव जगह हैं, लोकेशनेशंस
हैं, जहां पे हली सेंसिटिव लोकेशनेशंस
हैं, वो लोकेशनेशंस पे आपको थोड़े डिफरेंट
वेरिएशंस के पासवर्ड यूज़ करने हैं। सिंपल।
जैसे Gmail वगैरह की बात करें, वेबसाइट
पोर्टल्स, एडमिन पोर्टल्स की बात करें, तो
वहां आप अलग-अलग पासवर्ड्स को यूज़ कीजिए
ना। सब अलग करें। सिंपल। दैट दैट वुड बी
फाइन। ठीक है?
ओके। सो देयर इज द क्वेश्चन शिवम मिश्रा
के तरफ से। सर एक सवाल है आपका जो बग बंटी
प्लेलिस्ट है वह कर लेंगे तो बग फाइंड कर
पाएंगे क्योंकि मैं पैसे खर्च करके थक
चुका हूं। कोई रियल नहीं बता रहा। आप
जेन्युइन लगते हो। आप सजेशन दीजिए।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल। शिवम का यह क्वेश्चन है
जो मैंने अभी बताया आप लोगों को। इसका
आंसर आप यूज़र्स ही दे दीजिए जिन्होंने बग
बंटी वगैरह करा है ऑलरेडी जो मेरी लाइव
ट्रेनिंग है बग बंटी वाली प्लेलिस्ट उसको
अगर आपने करा है तो आप इसको जवाब दे दीजिए
आप शिवम ऑलरेडी जो लर्नर्स हैं जो
उन्होंने किया है वही आपको जवाब दे देंगे
क्योंकि मैं दूंगा तो हो सकता है मैं
बायस्ड हो आपको लगूं दे विल आंसर यू कि आप
बग बंटी वाली प्लेलिस्ट से क्या कुछ कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि मैंने देखा है Lindin पे
$5-5000 की बंटीज भी लोगों ने ली है एंड
दे हैव मेंशंड आवर बग बंटी प्लेलिस्ट आर
डेनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल सो देयर माइट
बी समथिंग राइट कुछ तो होगा बात तभी तो वो
फॉलो करके एंड हमें टैग करते हैं या हमें
क्रेडिट देते हैं राइट मेरे कह देने से कि
क्रेडिट दो तो कोई क्रेडिट नहीं देगा ना
जब तक उसको एक्चुअली फील नहीं होगा कि हां
क्रेडिट देना चाहिए अगर उसको वर्थ लगेगा
तभी तो देगा तो दैट शुड बी इनफ एज आंसर।
ठीक है? चलिए एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स में आ जाते
हैं। जब क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग की बात हो तो
एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स क्या किस तरह के
इंडिकेटर्स आप एक्सपेक्ट कर सकते हैं? लॉग
इन अटेम्प्ट्स फ्रॉम मल्टीपल आईपीस ये
सारे ब्रूट फ़ोर्स में कॉमन होगा आपका।
वैलिड यूजरनेम प्लस वैलिड पासवर्ड बट
अनयूज़ुअल लोकेशन। अब भैया क्योंकि ये
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग है तो आपका डेटा
ब्रीच में पासवर्ड मिला है, यूजरनेम मिला
है। तो वैलिड यूजरनेम वैलिड पासवर्ड तो
वहां पे आपको आ रहा है एसओसी में बट
लोकेशन गड़बड़ है भैया। इसका मतलब है कुछ तो
गड़बड़ है। अब जनरली आप हमेशा दिल्ली,
नोएडा, गुड़गांव,
गाजियाबाद, फरीदाबाद इन लोकेशन से लॉग इन
करते हैं। अचानक से एक लॉग इन मुंबई से
आने लगे आपके यूजरनेम पासवर्ड पे। अचानक
से एक कर्नाटका से आने लगे। अचानक से आपका
जम्मू कश्मीर से आने लगे। तो थोड़ा सस्प
सस्पिशन तो लगेगा ना भाई। हैं? जम्मू
कश्मीर नहीं होना चाहिए। वो ज्यादा
सस्िशियस लगेगा। तो ये इंडिकेटर्स की तरह
होगी। इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल अलर्ट्स। मतलब पता
नहीं है कहां-कहां से लॉगिस आ रहे हैं।
हाई लॉग इन सक्सेस आफ्टर मेनी फेलियर्स।
बहुत सारे फेलियर्स हुए हैं। फिर लॉग इन
के सक्सेससेस हो रहे हैं। तो ये भी बहुत
बड़ी गड़बड़ चीज है। तो ये क्रेडिशियल
स्टफिंग के सोसी इंडिकेटर्स है। राइट?
गॉट इट?
अब आते हैं एक और शानदार अटैक एमएफए फैटिक
अटैक। इसको बोलते हैं मल्टीपल मल्टीपल
फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन फैटिक अटैक। यह क्या
होता है? अटैकर इसमें क्या करता है? गेट्स
पासवर्ड ट्राई टू लॉग इन रिपीटेडली।
विक्टिम रिसीव्स मेनी एमएफए पुश
नोटिफिकेशंस। विक्टिम क्लिक्स अप्रूव्ड
आउट ऑफ फ्रस्ट्रेशन। यह फ्रस्ट्रेशन अटैक
है। दिस इज़ नॉट अ नॉर्मल अटैक। यह
फ्रस्ट्रेशन फ्रस्ट्रेटेड लोगों के लिए
अटैक है। कई बार होता है मान लो कोई
Google से ऐसा होता है ना फोन पर
नोटिफिकेशन जाके यस कर दो तो लॉग इन हो
जाता है। कई बार ऐसा भी होता है अगर कोई
सेम नोन नेटवर्क से या डिवाइस से कोई करे
आपके किसी लॉगिन पोर्टल में या ईमेल
पोर्टल्स पे या कई ऐसे वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस
ऐसे फीचर्स प्रोवाइड करते हैं। उस केस में
अटैकर्स को पासवर्ड तो पता होता है। अब
पासवर्ड के बाद मल्टीपल फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
लगा रहता है या टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन लगा
रहता है। अब वो क्या करता है? बार-बार
बार-बार ट्राई मारता है। विक्टिम बार काम
में है यार विक्टिम। अरे यार बार-बार ये
नोटिफिकेशन आ रहा है। क्या आ रहा है यार?
अच्छा अच्छा यस यस कुछ भी कर दिया मतलब
आउट ऑफ फ्रस्ट्रेशन अगर ऐसा हो जा रहा है
तो ये एमएफए फैटिक अटैक कहलाता है। एसओसीस
क्या देखते हैं इसको? मल्टीपल एमएफए
रिक्वेस्ट मल्टीपल टाइम्स मल्टीफैक्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन की रिक्वेस्ट्स आ रही हैं। अ
या दिस टाइप ऑफ़ फैटी अटैक्स हैपेंस
मल्टीपल टाइम्स। बिल्कुल पीतांबर। अ सो इस
तरह के जो फैटिक अटैक्स होते हैं इसको
एमएफ फैटिक अटैक कहते हैं। फॉललोड बाय
सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन और कई बार ऐसे रिक्वेस्ट
मल्टीपल टाइम जब आएंगे उसमें से कुछ
लॉगिनस सक्सेसफुल भी हो जाएंगे। तो ऐसा
अटैक होता है वेरी कॉमन इन एज योर एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी एनवायरमेंट्स। एज योर एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी एनवायरमेंट्स में ये थोड़ी
कॉमन पाए जाते हैं। ठीक है? देखो अब
पासवर्ड अटैक्स में सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
कि ये टारगेट किसको किए जाते हैं? किस
टाइप के चीजों को टारगेट किया जाता है
पासवर्ड अटैक्स में? तो सबसे पहले तो
आरडीपी जो सर्विज है रिमोट डेस्कटॉप
प्रोटोकॉल्स उनको मोस्टली ये ज्यादातर
टारगेट किए जाते हैं। जिनका पोर्ट नंबर
जनरली 3389 होता है। एसएसएच पोर्ट्स को
टारगेट किए जाते हैं क्योंकि ऑब्वियस सी
बात है लॉग इन पोर्ट्स ये कहलाते हैं या
एफटीपी पोर्ट्स यू कैन से टेलेट पोर्ट्स
यू कैन से तो ऐसे पोर्ट्स जो लॉग इन
पोर्ट्स कहलाते हैं उनको टारगेट किया जाता
है। तो ये वीपीए पोर्टल्स जो होते हैं
उनको टारगेट किया जा सकता है। ऑब्वियस सी
बात है वहां भी लॉग इन का खेल है। वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस जहां लॉग इन पैनल्स वगैरह
अवेलेबल है उनको टारगेट किया जा सकता है।
डेटाबेस लॉगिन पैनल्स को टारगेट किया जा
सकता है। यह सारे जो लॉग इन पैनल्स हैं
उसको टारगेट किया जाता है। पहले
फ्रस्ट्रेट करो और फिर हर्ट दे दो कि उसने
अप्रूव कर दिया बट नहीं करना। [हंसी]
सही है।
व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन बग बंटी एंड
डीएई प्लेलिस्ट। अरे डीए एथिकल हैकिंग की
प्लेलिस्ट है जो कि ईजीपीटी जैसे
सर्टिफिकेशंस पे बेस्ड है। बग बंटी एक
कंप्लीट वेब एप्लीकेशन पेन टेस्टिंग का
प्लेलिस्ट है जो कि अगर मैं बात करूं अ पे
एज पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की या मैं बात
करूं पेन टेस्टिंग की तो उसमें वेब
एप्लीकेशन वाले पार्ट को कवर करता है। पेन
टेस्टिंग में वेब एप्लीकेशन पेंट
टेस्टिंग, मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन पेंट
टेस्टिंग, Android iOS पेंट टेस्टिंग हो
गई, थिक थिन एंड एपीआई पेंट टेस्टिंग, गीब
पेंट सब चीज़ होती है। उसमें वेब एप्लीकेशन
वाला ओएस टॉप 10 कंप्लीटली कवर करता है बग
बाउंट की प्लेलिस्ट। तो प्लीज आप इस चीज
को ध्यान रखिए इस डिफरेंस को। अब अटैक चेन
का मैं एग्जांपल देता हूं। किस तरीके से
अटैक चेन ये काम करता है पासवर्ड अटैक का।
राइट? पहले फिशिंग ईमेल आती है। फिशिंग
ईमेल से क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुराया जाता है।
उसके बाद अटैकर जो है वीपीए ट्राई करता
है। एनएफए इनेबल है तो भैया फेल हो जाते
हैं। अटैकर अटेमप्ट्स पासवर्ड स्प्रे वही
पासवर्ड स्प्रे पासवर्ड स्प्रे यूज़ करता
है। फाइंड वीक सर्विस अकाउंटेड एंड देन
गेस इंटरनल एक्सेस एंड देन इंटरनल एक्सेस
गेन करता है। ठीक है? तो पासवर्ड स्प्रे
काफी ज्यादा अ वर्किंग
टाइप ऑफ थिंग्स पॉसिबल है क्योंकि मल्टीपल
यूज़र्स पे एक पासवर्ड का कॉम्बिनेशन एक ही
पासवर्ड को ट्राई किया जाता है तो चांसेस
थोड़े बढ़ जाते हैं यहां पे एंड लॉकआउ एंड
बैनिंग का खतरा कम हो जाता है थोड़ा सा
राइट तो ये पूरा का पूरा एक अटैक चेन है
जो फॉलो होता है। ठीक है? जनरली अब यह जो
अटैक चेन है मेनली अह रसमवेयर केसेस में
भी काफी ज़्यादा देखने को मिल जाता है। अब
एसओसी एल1 का इन्वेस्टिगेशन वर्क फ्लो
क्या रहने वाला है इस तरह के पासवर्ड
अटैक्स के ऊपर में? व्हाट व्हाट शुड बी द
इन्वेस्टिगेशन वर्क फ्लो? अगर आप एक एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एल1 है तो आपका वर्क फ्लो क्या
होना चाहिए? व्हेन यू गेट एन अलर्ट
जैसे ऐसे मल्टीपल फेल लॉग इन आइटम्स। ऐसा
कुछ अलर्ट आपको मिला। तो अब आपको क्या चेक
करना है? सबसे पहले सोर्स आईपी चेक करनी
है कि भई यह आईपी कुछ गड़बड़ तो नहीं है
आईपी कहां से हो रही है अपने इंटरनल आईपी
से या कहीं बाहर से कुछ आईपी जिओ लोकेशन
आपके नोन लोकेशन से ये अटेंप्ट्स हो रहे
हैं या किसी अननोन लोकेशन से अटेम्प्ट्स
हो रहे हैं यूजरनेम टारगेट्स इट्स किस
टाइप के यूज़र्स को या यूजरनेम्स को टारगेट
किया जा रहा है कोई मोर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
यूज़र्स को टारगेट किया जा रहा है मोर
जिसके पास ज्यादा पावर है ठीक है ज्यादा
जिसके पास परमिशंस है उनको टारगेट किया जा
रहा है या जेरिक यूज़र्स को टारगेट किया जा
रहा है सक्सेस और ओनली फेलर्स। सिर्फ
फेलियर्स ही हो रहे हैं कि सक्सेस भी कहीं
हुए। सक्सेस हुए हैं तो फिर तो ये थोड़ी
सी सोचने वाली बात है। टाइम फ्रीक्वेंसी
बहुत टाइम पे हो रहा है। बहुत डिले डिले
पे हो रहा है या बहुत फ्रीक्वेंट हो रही
है। डिले पे हो रही है। हो सकता है कोई एक
जेन्युइन यूजर ही ट्राई मार रहा हो।
बेचारा पासवर्ड भूल गया हो या कोई भी यू
मैसेज ट्राई कर सकता है। जेन्युइन बट अगर
बहुत फ्रीक्वेंट हो रहा है बहुत
जल्दी-जल्दी हो रहा है तो फिर गड़बड़ है।
अकाउंट लॉकआउट ट्रिगरर्ड। अकाउंट लॉग आउट
हो लॉकआउट हुआ है कि नहीं हुआ? और पासवर्ड
ब्रूटफोर्स के अटैक के देखो अकाउंट लॉकउ
का खतरा सबसे ज्यादा किस में होता है?
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक में या पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग अटैक में? बताइए मुझे। लेट मी
नो। तो इसी से पता चल जाएगा आप कितना
ध्यान दे रहे हैं। अभी जितने लोग भी यहां
पे हैं। इससे पता चलेगा कि कितना ध्यान दे
रहे हैं। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक में अकाउंट
लॉकआउट का खतरा ज्यादा होता है या पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग अटैक में।
लेट मी नो। एवरीबॉडी मुझे ज्यादा से
ज्यादा कमेंट्स ज्यादा से ज्यादा रिप्लाई
चाहिए।
बहुत धीरे-धीरे आ रहे हैं रिप्लाई भाई।
ऐसा क्यों? जल्दी करो। एक बोल रहा है
श्रीपद
जी बोल रहे हैं पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग। गलत
आंसर है। द रियल आंसर इज़ ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक। बिल्कुल सही। ब्रूटf अटैक में
ज्यादा अकाउंट लॉकआउ एंड अकाउंट्स
ब्लैकिस्ट या आईपी ब्लैकिस्ट होने के
चांसेस ज्यादा होते हैं। पासवर्ड
स्प्रेइंग में कंपेरेटिवली टू आपका ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स लेस चांसेस होता है। एनी सक्सेसफुल
लॉग इन आफ्टर फेलर्स कोई सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन
हुआ है या नहीं हुआ है। तो ये जो चीजें
हैं ये आपको थोड़ी सी नोटिस करनी है। अगर
इनका कोई भी मतलब अगर इस तरीके से जब आप
चीज़ों को क्वेश्चंस करेंगे खुद के कि भैया
सोर्स आईपी क्या है? ऐसा कुछ डिफरेंट है
या कुछ है? कोई सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन आफ्टर
फेलियर्स हुआ है। ऐसा कुछ होता है? यस तो
इसको एस्केलेट कर दीजिए कि भैया तुम अपना
जिम्मेदारी L2 L3 वाले संभालो। हम तो चलते
हैं। बस
ठीक है? इंपॉर्टेंट लॉग्स टू मास्टर। कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट लॉग्स हैं जिनको आपको मास्टर
करना चाहिए। समझना चाहिए। Windows के अंदर
में कुछ इस तरीके के 4625 इसका मतलब फेल
लॉग इन है। 4624 सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन होता
है। 476 एनtएलएम ऑथेंटिकेशन का 4740
अकाउंट लॉगउ। कुछ इस तरीके के कुछ लॉग्स
होते हैं। अब ये लॉग्स तो आपको भाई
प्रैक्टिस करते-करते समझ में आ जाएंगे।
थोड़ा मेमोराइज़ हो जाएगा। एंड जैसे-जैसे
आप प्रैक्टिस करेंगे यू विल गेट टू
अंडरस्टैंड। ठीक है? यू विल अंडरस्टैंड।
लinक्स में ये एक पाथ है वेयर log ऑथ डॉट
log। इसके अंदर आपको इंटरव्यू एंड आपको
लॉग्स मिल जाएंगे। एसएसएस लॉग इन
अटेम्प्ट्स जो है वो आपको देखने को वहां
पे मिलेगा। फायरवल में रिपीटेड कनेक्शन
अटेमप्ट्स एंड ब्लॉक्ड कनेक्शन स्पाइक्स
ये आपको देखने को मिल जाता है। ये एल1 का
इन्वेस्टिगेशन वर्क फ्लो है जो आपको समझना
चाहिए। समझना एज अ एसोसिएट एल1 आपको ये
चीजों का ध्यान रखना चाहिए। जब भी आप
पासवर्ड अटैक्स के ऊपर काम कर रहे हैं। जब
भी आप डैशबोर्ड्स को मॉनिटर कर रहे हैं और
इस तरह की कुछ चीजें हो रही हैं तो
पासवर्ड अटैक्स हो रही हैं और अलग-अलग तरह
के पासवर्ड अटैक्स हो रहे हैं। उस पे आपको
अलग-अलग तरह के एकशंस लेने हैं। चाहे वो
आपको आईपी ब्लैक लिस्ट करनी हो, चाहे आपका
लोकेशन ब्लैकिस्ट करना हो, चाहे आपको
पर्टिकुलर बंदे को ही ब्लैकिस्ट आई बंदा
ब्लैकिस्ट करना हो, कुछ भी करना है आपको
अटैक को रोकना है। ठीक है?
प्रिवेंशन मैकेनिज्म की बात करें तो आप
जनरली एक कंपनी के अंदर में एक नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी के तौर पे अकाउंट लॉकर पॉलिसी
होनी चाहिए। मल्टीपल फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन या
टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिक कम से कम टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन तो होने चाहिए। बट एमएफए अगर
है मल्टीपल फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन दैट वुड बी
मच बेटर। रेट लिमिटिंग बिल्कुल होनी
चाहिए। कैप्चा होना ही चाहिए क्योंकि
कैप्चा अगर नहीं होगा तो फिर ऑटोमेटिक
बॉट्स जो हैं जो बॉट्स ऑटोमेटिक बॉट नहीं
बॉट्स जो हैं वो ज्यादा कचरा करेंगे अ
ज्यादा
आपको दिक्कत देंगे। Jio ब्लॉकिंग होना
चाहिए। लोकेशन वाइज ब्लॉकिंग स्ट्रांग
पासवर्ड्स का पॉलिसी होना चाहिए। एंड
डिफ़ॉल्ट अकाउंट्स को डिसेबल करके रखिए
ताकि डिफ़ॉल्ट अकाउंट्स पे ब्रूटf अटैक ना
किया जाए। मल्टीपल ब्रूटफोर्स अटैक जो है
डिफॉल्ट अकाउंट्स इनेबल होने के कारण
सक्सेसफुल हो जाते हैं क्योंकि वो इनेबल्ड
होते हैं। ठीक है? जैसे डिफॉल्ट अकाउंट
में एडमिन हो गया, रूट हो गया। ऐसे कुछ
डिफॉल्ट अकाउंट्स होते हैं।
अगर मैं अटैक्स की कंपैरिजन की बात करूं
तो मैं ब्रूटf अटैक की जब बात करता हूं तो
ये हाई स्पीड का अटैक होता है। डिटेक्शन
इसकी इजी हो जाती है। एंड एसओसी में बहुत
ही कॉमन आपका ये होता है। जो आपका एसओसी
में कॉमन बहुत वेरी कॉमन होता है ये ब्रूट
अटैक। मैं बात करूं डिक्शनरी की तो यह
मीडियम स्पीड पर काम करती है। इसका
डिटेक्शन मीडियम लेवल का डिटेक्शन इसका भी
हो जाता है। एंड यह भी बहुत ज्यादा ही
कॉमन होता है। पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग की बात
करूं तो यह स्लो होता है। ठीक है?
डिटेक्शन बहुत हार्ड है इसकी डिटेक्शन।
मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला है कि इसमें
चांसेस कम होते हैं लॉकआउट वगैरह के। एंड
ये भी काफी कॉमन होता है। क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग की बात करूं तो ये भी मीडियम
स्पीड की होती है। ये भी हार्ड टू डिटेक्ट
होती है। एंड ये भी बहुत कॉमन होती है।
हाइब्रिड ट्रैक की बात करूं तो मीडियम
होती है इसकी स्पीड। इसकी डिटेक्शन भी
मीडियम होती है। एंड यह भी काफी कॉमन होता
है। रेनबो टेबल में जब हम आते हैं तो यह
ऑफलाइन अटैक होता है एक तरह का। बहुत
हार्ड डिटेक्शन है। एंड यह पोस्ट ब्रीच जो
होती है उस पे यह यूज़ में लिया जाता है।
एमएफए फैटिक की बात करूं तो यह सबसे
ज्यादा स्टिल्थ अटैक माना जाता है। बहुत
हार्ड डिटेक्शन होती है। एंड ये इसकी अभी
करेंटली जो है ये एसओसी के अंदर इस इसमें
इंक्रीमेंट देखा जा रहा है एमएफ फैटिक
अटैक्स में। जैसे कि अभी रिसेंटली एक
लर्नर है
क्या नाम था यार?
यस पीतांबर। तो इन्होंने बोला ही था
क्योंकि ही इज़ ऑलरेडी एन एसओसी। तो एमएफए
फैटिक अटैक काफी ज्यादा कॉमन होते जा रहे
हैं। तो यह एक अटैक कंपैरिजन है। राइट?
ओके। अच्छा गाइस ये बताओ मुझे पीपीटी आप
लोगों को सही लगती है? पीपीटी में मजा आता
है। पीपीटी ठीक लगती है। पीपीटी में आपको
जब मैं देता हूं एज अ पीडीएफ फॉर्मेट तो
आपको समझ में आता है पीपीटी के अंदर में
सारी चीजें स्लाइड्स के अंदर में जो चीजें
मेंशन क्योंकि मैं चाहता हूं पीपीटी के
अंदर में कोशिश करता हूं कि मल्टी
मैक्सिमम एक्सप्लेन एंड मैक्सिमम आपको जो
है वो डिटेलिंग प्रोवाइड कर दी जाए ताकि
आपके लिए थोड़ा इजी हो जाए। राइट?
ठीक है। ठीक है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। अगर
समझ में आ रहा है तो ये अटैक कंपैरिजनंस
थे। तो ये जो सारी चीजें थी आपकी पासवर्ड
अटैक्स के रिगार्डिंग थी आज के सेशन में।
अब पासवर्ड अटैक्स में और भी चीजें हैं।
ठीक है? तो हम उसको भी जानेंगे नेक्स्ट
सेशन में। उसमें अ लाइक अभी हैशिंग के
बारे में मैंने आपको नहीं बताया। सॉल्टिंग
के बारे में नहीं बताया मैंने आपको।
इंक्रिप्शन के बारे में नहीं बताया।
मल्टीपल चीजें जो आपको जाननी पड़ेंगी। एंड
साथ में हम डॉस अटैक्स, डॉस, बॉट्स,
बॉटनेट्स, ज़ॉम्बीज़ ये सब चीजें भी
जानेंगे। तो मल्टीपल अभी बहुत सारी चीजें
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आनी बची है। वो आप सबको
मैं बताऊंगा धीरे-धीरे समझाऊंगा एंड आपको
मजा भी आएगा। बिलीव मी आपको जितना मजा
आएगा आपने सोचा भी नहीं होगा उतना मजा
आएगा। तो आप उसके लिए बेफिक्र रहिए। बस आप
डेडीकेशन एंड कंसिस्टेंसी दिखाइए। मैं बस
इतना ही आपसे रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा। दैट्स इट।
और कुछ भी आपसे मैं नहीं बोलता। डेडिकेशन
एंड कंसिस्टेंसी। दैट्स इट। चलिए यहां पे
है टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट को देखने का टाइम।
तो यहां पे हम टॉप फैंस पे आ जाते हैं।
एंड आई एम एक्सट्रीमली हैप्पी कि आप में
से कई लोग जो है वो रेगुलर अटेंड करते हैं
सेशंस को। रेगुलर वो करते हैं। एंड हां एक
चीज और मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं बिफोर
दैट कि आप जब भी वीडियोस को देखते हैं तो
आई डोंट नो कि यहां पे मुझे नहीं दिखाएगा।
बट आपके जब वीडियोस खत्म हो जाते हैं जब
आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं तो वहां पे नीचे
में एक हाइप का बटन होता है। देयर इज़ एन
बटन नोन एज हाइप। आप में से कई लोगों को
शायद पता होगा हाइप का बटन होता है। डू यू
नो अबाउट हाइप। आपको हाइप का बटन पता है?
हाइप होता है। यू नो अ एक हाइप करते हैं
वीडियोस को जिससे वीडियोस को ज्यादा
सजेस्ट किया जाता है YouTube के द्वारा।
जितनी ज्यादा हाइप्ड होंगी वीडियोस वो
उतनी ज्यादा YouTube रिकमेंड करता है।
सजेस्ट करता है एंड वो ट्रेंड करने की
कोशिश करता है वीडियो। तो आप हाइप जरूर कर
दिया कीजिएगा। सो दैट इट विल हेल्प दोज़
वीडियोस टू रीच टू वाइडर ऑडियंसेस। जो
सिमिलर ऑडियंसेस हैं
वहां तक पहुंचे। ठीक है? धन्यवाद। अब टॉप
फैंस पे आ जाते हैं। तो यहां पे है मिस्टर
जट टॉप। यह तो हमेशा रहते ही हैं। ऋषु द
रूट बिलकुल अमित यादव बढ़िया। फोर स्कल
गौरव जांगरा ओके जेडी कोडर साइबरन नक्स
दयानंद स्वरी ओके इट्स स्टाइलिन नाम
प्रोनंसिएशन में गलती हो तो माफ़ करना भाई।
हसनबर्ग हसनबर्ग ओके साहिल्स रोहित मिस्टर
रोबोट नमन मनीष प्रिंस कंचन
पीतांबर खलीद खलीद पता नहीं क्या नाम है
प्रवीण अ श्रीपद श्रीपद
कश्मीरा
ओके अभिषेक अमन मौर्य निशा चौधरी राय
पटीदार
ओके फाइन फैंस कॉम हमजा एंड बहुत सारे लोग
हैं। अरुण सबका नाम तो मैं नहीं ले सकता
हूं। जगतगुरु स्वामी ओके आदि आदि की आर्ट
ओके PUBG ओके आदि की आर्ट ओके गोविंद साहू
मास्टर पीस साइबर क्यूब्स ओके ठीक है सो
देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स थैंक यू वेरी मच
फॉर बीइंग कंसिस्टेंट फॉर बीइंग फॉर लॉन्ग
टाइम लंबे टाइम तक आप यहां पे एक्टिव रहते
हैं इंटरेक्ट करते हैं थैंक यू फॉर दैट
ओके सर हाउ टू आइडेंटिफाई व्हिच कोर्स आर
जेन्युइन एंड व्हिच आर फेक इसमें कोई ऐसे
आइडेंटिफाई करने की आपके अंदर अपनी हुनर
होनी चाहिए ठीक है वो आपकी अपनी हुनर होनी
चाहिए। आप उससे आइडेंटिफाई कीजिए। कोई
नहीं बता सकता कि कैसे आइडेंटिफाई करते
हैं।
ठीक है? सो गाइज़ दैट्स ऑल फॉर टुडेेस
सेशन। आई होप यू एंजॉयड द सेशन। आज का
सेशन 1.5 आवर्स का ही रखते हैं। क्योंकि
आज के सेशन में मेरे को जितना आपको बताना
था जो आपके लिए इनफ था वो मैंने आपको
बताया है। अब आपका एक काम क्या होगा कि
आपको ये जो टॉपिक्स हैं जैसे ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक हो गई। जैसे आपके डिक्शनरी अटैक्स हो
गए, हाइब्रिड अटैक्स हो गए, आपका रेनबूबल
अटैक हो गया, रिवर्स ब्रूड फ़ोर्स अटैक हो
गई, क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग हो गई। इसके बारे
में आप जाके खुद से भी रिसर्च करेंगे,
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे एंड उसको पढ़ेंगे। एंड
इसको वापस से रिवाइज करेंगे। साथ ही में
रिवाइज करने के बाद जैसा कि मैंने पहले ही
बताया Lindin पे आके आप पोस्ट करेंगे।
Lindin पे आप देखेंगे यहां पे बहुत सारे
जो हैं जैसे इन्होंने विदिशा करके हैं।
इन्होंने जैसे यहां पे डाल ये हर डे का
डालते रहते हैं। तो यहां पे जैसे इन्होंने
डे सेवन का लास्ट डाला हुआ है कि फिशिंग
एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करा। उसमें
क्या-क्या पढ़ा, क्या-क्या टॉपिक्स थे वो
सारी चीजें। एंड इनके हैंड रिटेन नोट्स
होते हैं जो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग काफी अच्छे
भी होते हैं। तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
कुछ इस तरीके के नोट्स ये खुद के भी बनाते
हैं। इसी तरीके के नोट्स आपको खुद के भी
बनाने हैं। एंड डेफिनेटली दीज़ विल बी वेरी
वेरी हेल्पफुल फॉर यू गाइस। आई एम आई आई
मस्ट से आप देख सकते हैं मैंने इसको लाइक
भी करा हुआ है। सो आई सी ऑल द कंटेंट्स
एंड एवरीथिंग ऑन Lindin एंड हो सकता है
मैं कुछ में लाइक या कमेंट ना कर पाऊं। बट
मोस्टली आई सी ऑल द थिंग्स। राइट? तो इसी
तरीके से आपको यहां पे लिन पे डालना है और
टैग करना है हमें इस तरीके से जैसे
इन्होंने यहां पे टैग किया हुआ है। ये काम
आपको करना है। WhatsApp ग्रुप ज्वाइन कर
लेनी है एंड WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो कर
लेना है। डिफरेंस Academy WhatsApp पे
आपको मिल जाएगा। ये Instagram ये वेबसाइट
एंड ये हमारी Lindin का एंड ये हमारा एक्स
का पेज। राइट? सो दैट्स ऑल फॉर टुडे सेशन
गाइस। एंड आई होप कि यू एंजॉयड द सेशन। आई
होप यू गेन समथिंग न्यू एंड समथिंग रियल।
बस जो फ्लो चल रहा है उसको चलने दीजिए।
जिस तरीके से मैं आपको बता रहा हूं उसी
तरीके से आप आगे बढ़िए। प्लीज ज्यादा अपने
दिमाग को मत यूज़ कीजिए। अभी फिलहाल के
लिए मैं आपको क्लियर कट सीधा डायरेक्ट बोल
रहा हूं। जैसे मैं बता रहा हूं वैसे आप
चलते जाइए। ज्यादा ज्यादा कुछ अप्लाई नहीं
करना है। बस जो मैं बोलूं जैसा बोलूं जिस
तरीके से मैं जिस फ्लो में ला रहा हूं उस
फ्लो में आप आगे बढ़िए। आई होप कि यू विल
गेट सक्सेस एंड यू विल गेन द स्किल्स दैट
इज रिक्वायर्ड फॉर बिकमिंग अ जॉब रेडी
एसओसी एल1। थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर दिस सेशन
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में बहुत जल्द
आगे इसको कंटिन्यू करते हुए। चलिए टाटा
बाय-ब गाइस एंड गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि सभी
को। एक बार शुभ रात्रि कर दो फिर चलते
हैं। गुड नाइट। बाय।
ओके। ओके गाइस बाय।